So, da bin ich.
Das Leben ist hart.
Unter anderem
bei den chinesischen China-Chinesen
kaufen wir einen. Genau, aber
unter anderem. Ich habe ein paar
Sachen, muss ich mal gucken.
Was davon bei
was davon bei
AliExpress gibt. Ihr werdet es
nicht glauben, Leute.
Was ich gerade für eine Mail bekommen
habe. Sponsoring-Anfrage.
Ihr kommt
nicht drauf. Nie im Leben.
Chat, ratet mal.
Ray Shadow Legends, genau.
Die Leute wissen es.
Sponsored. Ray Shadow Legends
Promotion.
Von irgendjemand, den ich
nicht aussprechen kann vom Namen
Yal
Khoison.
Bestimmt Poggers.
Poggers, Leute.
So, wollen wir mal gucken.
Wollen wir mal gucken,
was die so rausrücken
für Ray.
Shadow Legends. Also.
Hi, Wubblorz.
Wubblorz.
Ich kann doch nicht meinen Namen richtig schreiben.
Lul, weh, Alter.
Okay.
Hope you are doing well.
I'm reaching out
in regards to a sponsorship
opportunity.
Raid Shadow Legends.
Deployed by
Stream Elements. Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass Stream Elements was damit zu tun haben.
Okay.
So, also. Was die
wollen. Also, passt mal auf.
Was wollen die? Die wollen
Requirements.
Zwei Stunden Sponsored
Gameplay. Am besten
mit oder am Ende vom Stream.
Dass schon vorher richtig viel Viewership
da ist. Man ist klar, wenn einer mit Ray Shadow Legends
startet, schaltet der keine Sau ein.
Ähm. Dann muss ich
auf zwei. Das steht da wirklich drin.
Ich muss auf zwei Trailer reacten.
Während dem Stream.
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich dann auch die Trailer
vorgegeben, auf die ich zu reacten habe.
Zu Raid Shadow Legends. Und wahrscheinlich auch, was ich
sagen darf und was nicht.
So, ähm.
Dann irgendwie einen Tracking Link
Overlay.
Raid Shadow Legends Overlay on Stream.
Chatbot mit Raid Shadow Legends
Tracking Link.
Und ein Twitter Post.
Social Media before going live
mit Raid Shadow Legends Link.
Die wollen es.
Aber echt, wir sind jetzt hier.
Was gibt's denn dafür? Zeig mal her.
Was gibt's denn für Money?
Was gibt's denn da für eine Kohle für?
Wo schreibe ich das denn?
Wo? Oh, Sekunde.
Easy Money. Wo steht's denn?
Okay, sie stellen mir alle Sachen
zur Verfügung, die ich für den Stream brauche.
Das wäre noch schöner, wenn ich ein eigenes Raid Shadow Legends
Overlay anfertigen müsste.
Ähm.
Also Base Pay sind
500 Dollar.
Minus 15%.
Hä?
Was soll mir das denn sagen? Base Pay?
500 Dollar minus 15%.
Hä?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ähm, so, okay, es geht weiter.
Es geht weiter. Okay.
Ähm.
Die meinen plus 15%.
Glaube ich, nicht minus.
Okay, was auch immer. Ich versteh's nicht.
Ich versteh's nicht. Weißt du, was die wollen?
So. Und das
increased
um 45%.
Minus 15%.
Was auch immer die mir damit sagen wollen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ähm.
Wenn. Das ist, das ist.
Leute, Leute, es ist so, es ist so.
Ich check's nicht.
Es ist so geschrieben, dass ich es ernsthaft nicht verstehe,
was die wollen. Dann, ich schreibe dann
zwischendrin noch irgendwas.
If you end
Dollar 900 von
Dollar 1053
Members of your community
reach level 100.
Ja, aber warum Dollar? Und warum 900 von
1350? Was zum Teufel wollen die von mir?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Kann das sein, dass da eine
Variable drinstehen soll? Und
dieses E-Mail-Programm von denen hat die Variable
nicht richtig eingesetzt?
Dass da irgendein Prozent drinne steht?
Oder so?
Hm. Oh, oh.
Beautiful Deal Structure.
Oh ja, alles klar. Ich bin schon komplett
Mysterion, danke schön für 500 Subscription.
Ich bin schon super überzeugt, Great Channel Legends
Sponsoring hier zu machen. Also.
Es steht an irgendwas von 1350
Dollar. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob die wirklich Dollar meinen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Beautiful. Wisst ihr, was beautiful daran ist?
Wenn ich öfters Great Channel Legends
Werbung mache, dann zählt es
zu den
Leveln dazu. Also, wenn ich jetzt ein
Sponsoring mache und dann in zwei Wochen
und ihr erreicht erst in zwei Wochen Level 100,
dann krieg ich trotzdem Geld.
Bam.
Was ein Scheiß, Alter.
Ich werde dieses Spiel niemals
zeigen, geschweige denn spielen.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung. Also, dieser
Post ist so dermaßen schlecht geschrieben, dass du
noch nicht mal verstehst, was die eigentlich von dir wollen.
Wahnsinn. Echt Wahnsinn.
Great Channel Legends.
Keck, wait.
Na gut.
So.
Kannst du ein Shit-Hub-Tutorial
machen, in dem, was in einem
der letzten Spiele hast du Git?
Hm. Ja, gut.
Git-MV hat mit
GitHub hier erst einmal nichts zu tun.
GitHub ist ja nur ein Frontend.
Willst du ein Git-Tutorial oder willst du ein
Shit-Hub-Tutorial?
Shit-Hub-Tutorial.
Ja, ich mir auch, aber ich will diesen...
Ich gönn's denen nicht.
Ich gönn's Great Channel Legends nicht.
Beides machen, please.
Ein Shit-Tutorial haben wir sogar
schon mal vor Urzeiten gemacht, aber
das war so eher aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt.
Äh, Manjaro.
Hier, guck, da. Ups.
Falsche VM. Hier. Manjaro Linux.
Beste dafür.
Mehr als ein Terminal
und ein Browser brauchst du da nicht drin.
Aber du siehst, es läuft wirklich
wunderbar zackig. Und wir haben sogar,
ja, GLX-Gears, Max-FPS
am Start.
Also, ich hab Manjaro
sowohl in der VM mit i3 als auch
auf meinem Notebook auf der Arbeit.
Passt wunderbar.
Ach so, by the way, ich sollte es vielleicht noch mal
sagen, man spricht es nicht shit aus.
Nicht, dass ihr den gleichen Fehler macht
wie der eine Azubi bei uns, ja. Das muss nicht sein.
Kannst du mal ein Tutorial
zu i3 machen? Da gibt's...
Nee, da braucht man kein Tutorial zu.
Das ist total easy.
Das ist gut vorkonfiguriert
und du brauchst...
Du brauchst drei Shortcuts im Endeffekt.
Du brauchst Mod-Taste Enter
für Terminal, du brauchst
Mod-Taste 1, 2, 3 für Desktop
wechseln. Jo, das war's
im Prinzip.
i3 ist das hier, diese Oberfläche, die du hier siehst.
Das Gute an der i3-Config
ist, dass die relativ
gut standardmäßig beschrieben
ist, was was macht und dass die Default-Config
vollkommen in Ordnung ist.
Du musst da eigentlich erst mal gar nichts umstellen.
So.
Also, wie gesagt, i3 ist die Oberfläche.
Die ich hier verwende, da.
So.
Okay.
Oh, mal gucken, Leute.
Geht das PPGA-Board
eigentlich? Leute, das PPGA-Board
ist kaputt.
Moment, das müssen wir jetzt testen.
Wo bloß? Test.
PPGA-Board ist kaputt.
Das geht nicht. Warum nicht?
Hat
Twitch die IRC
API abgestellt oder so? Wartet mal.
Schreibt
nochmal.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Okay.
Also, ich hab Manjaro
mit dem Architekt-Installer installiert
und dann alles selbst installiert.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen nerviger.
Lulwe kekwe. So sieht's aus.
Sehe ich genauso. Okay. Also.
Haben wir noch ein paar Questions, bevor wir anfangen.
Irgendjemand, hab ich hier was mit Kubuntu gelesen
oder sowas. Ja, hier.
Meine Freundin hat aktuell Kubuntu.
Aber auf Bugs.
Ja, Ubuntu auf dem Desktop ist
leider nicht das, was es mal war.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Also für deine, ich weiß nicht, wie
technikversiert deine Freundin ist.
Ähm.
Wenn es ähnlich zu
Mac sein darf, dann
Elementary OS.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, Mädels
gefällt Elementary OS. Ansonsten
würde ich einfach Linux Mint nehmen. Da
kannst du nicht allzu viel falsch machen. Auch für
Einsteiger. Und
wenn du nix, wenn du, wenn du, war was?
anderes ausprobieren willst, was ich aber auch ganz
gut fand für Einsteiger und du kein
Problem damit hast, dass es eine China, eine China
Distribution ist, dann
nehmen Deepin Linux. Zumindest mal ausprobieren.
Die fand ich nämlich echt gut für das, was ich
ausprobiert hab.
Aber
es ist halt ein Chinesen Linux, ne. Das muss einem
muss einem halt klar sein.
Alternativ, ich weiß nicht, ob deine,
wenn deine Freundin Anime-Fan
ist, hätte ich auch was für dich
zu bieten.
Dann, wie wär's mit Moubuntu?
Dann kriegst du so hier eine
Augenweite an Distribution.
Guck dir das mal an.
Ja.
Ja, also ich mein, viel
besser geht's eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Also ich mein, das kann man schlecht noch toppen,
muss man ehrlich mal sagen, ne.
So, machen wir mal wieder aus.
Gut, schnell noch mal Chat gucken.
Ja, was hast denn du installiert?
Wie gesagt, gerade
Gnome-basierte Sachen sind extrem
laggy oftmals in der
VM. Lubuntu geht auch,
ja. Aber ich mag
Mint eigentlich ganz gern. Aber am besten
am besten die,
die, was ist Default?
Cinnamon ist Default mittlerweile, ne.
Also wenn ich nicht i3 verwenden würde,
würde ich ehrlich gesagt irgendwas XFCE
basiertes verwenden.
Oder Openbox. Openbox
hab ich früher auch verwendet.
Oder was, Fluxbox? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Das ist das ISO, wo nix vorinstalliert ist.
Leute, kauf mir nen
Whirlpool, genau.
Das kannst du ausprobieren, das funktioniert nicht.
Das hat noch keiner geschafft, der zu injecten.
Wo hast du
noch mal deine Forever Workstation Lizenz
gekauft? Bei Softwarekong.
Klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja,
ich weiß.
Warte mal, Leute, ich hab irgendwas übersehen,
was ich noch beantworten wollte.
Was ich auf dem anderen Chat gelesen hab.
Welche Produkte von
Shelly verwendest du? Das kann ich kurz zeigen.
Ich find's immer noch fail,
dass die Dinger
switch to tap.
Moment, warum haben wir die noch offen hier?
Ah, weil das das PP gab,
weil das die andere VM ist.
Moment, ich muss hier in die VM.
Das ist die richtige VM.
Also, ich kann dir sagen, welche
ich habe und dann sag ich dir, welche ich
verwende. Verwenden tu ich davon ein paar.
Die hab ich auch schon am längsten.
Den hab ich hier liegen, hab ich noch nicht
verwendet. Hab ich aber auch
vor. Dann hab ich...
Ich glaube noch ein...
Plug.
Einfach mal zum ausprobieren. Irgendwann mal
gekauft, hab ich aber auch nicht in Verwendung.
Also in Verwendung hab ich eigentlich nur
die. Den hab ich glaub ich
auch mal gekauft zum ausprobieren.
Ich glaub davon hab ich auch noch
mal ein Pack gekauft.
Aber die hab ich auch noch nicht
eingebaut.
Ne, ich glaube ich habe wirklich
nur
davon welche in Benutzung.
ZDE2586
POCK
Huge Hyper Subscription hier.
Big Brain Sub.
So. Ja, so siehts aus.
Das hab ich gerade im Einsatz.
Machen wir mal Amazon auf.
So, hatte ich jetzt alles durch im Chat?
Bringts richtig nice, wie viele Leute in letzter Zeit
am Start sind. Ups, nicht KeckWade, alter.
PostChamp.
Ich PostChamp.
Man muss sagen, es zahlt sich halt immer
aus, wenn man viel streamt, ne?
Ich hab letzten, letzten, glaub zwei Wochen
relativ viel gestreamt, jetzt sind wieder viele Leute am Start.
Ok.
Nee, Popo, es hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ja, korrekt.
Also XFCNRVM
ist auch ziemlich gut.
Ey, das passt, das passt sogar
ziemlich gut dazu.
Mr. Xzzz
Twitch Prime Gaming, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich muss übrigens mal hier aufmachen, weil ich
hab letzter Zeit den Hangar zu Subs zu übersehen.
Aber ich glaub diesmal hab ich
super sind so cool auf wisch wollen wir mal gucken ob es das da gibt wartet mal
wir gucken auf alibaba wenn ich auf alibaba auf aliexpress aliexpress ob es
hot hot tubes gibt hot tubes was habe ich da jetzt angeklickt
geste fort oder waren apple logo meint ihr bei aliexpress auch dass das echte
legit apple sachen sind die man da bekommt ja hot tube exquisite guck mal
hier classic luxury eine badewanne kann ich mir bestellen bei aliexpress jawohl
oder ein whirlpool für 5000 euro
ich glaube den würde ich bin ich den wird was was zum moment ist das für
mädels dass die draußen pinkeln können wie ein kerl
das habe ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen bei einem anderen shop aber ich bin ich
bin überrascht dass aliexpress das bei hot tube
bewerten
ich hab bei aliexpress immer angst dass monka tos bilder drauf sind
whirlpool so viel gibt's da nicht also ich kann meine badewanne eine luxus
badewanne kaufen titanium floor moun shower sieht das sieht das in irgendeiner
art und war doch da hängt eine schauer moment moment man kauft nicht die
badewanne man kauft die mann kauft die dusche man kauft gar nicht die badewanne
das ist debate
Auf die dusche haha das ist ja verarscht
von den china chinesen wieder alle
Aroha kaiser deutschland ist es dauert nur eineinhalb monat nehmen um ein zwei monate das liefern zu lassen
fedex liefert das exquisite für 40 euro
tja
also
oder oder ich kaufe mir oder ich kaufe mir ernsthaft ich kaufe mir den wirt
fuck
sag mal kann aliexpress mal in irgendeiner art und weise
sag mal warum hat aliexpress zweimal die gleiche suche und dann zwei komplett unterschiedliche guckt euch das an
das ist die gleiche suche da gibt es komplett unterschiedliche ergebnisse
ok ich guck mal hier kann ich mir den whirlpool kauft hat sogar schon zwei stück zwei stück haben den whirlpool bei aliexpress schon gekauft
jawoll
zweitens
eine bewertung
kundenbewertung
logistics ems
am bestellt das wundert mich nicht
am start alles klar
ich meine
gibt es wirklich gibt es
was sollte erkennt noch nicht mal was das sein soll gibt es wirklich leute die für
3000 euro den whirlpool auf aliexpress bestellen das kann ich mir vorstellen
Wenn ich 3.000 Euro ausgebe, kriege ich doch hier wahrscheinlich auch schon irgendwas.
So, was kostet hier ein Whirlpool?
Was kostet ein Whirlpool, wenn ich mir den kaufen will?
So, sogar noch billiger.
Warum soll ich das bei AliExpress kaufen?
Aufblasbarer Whirlpool.
Ja.
Zeus Riesen Whirlpool.
Und hier gibt es einen für nur 13.000 Euro.
Und das ist der gleiche wie bei AliExpress.
Schwachsinn.
Naja.
Brauchen wir eh nicht.
So.
Also, jetzt aber ganz schnell den Chat fertig machen.
Also, Puh.
Wie hieß noch mal die MikroTik-Switch, die du dir empfohlen hast?
Das kann ich dir sagen, wenn du mir sagst, für was ich die empfohlen habe.
Also, den, den ich mir zuletzt gekauft habe, das ist der hier gewesen.
Aber den würde ich gar nicht mal zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt so sehr empfehlen.
Weil, ich meine, der steht hier.
Der steht immer noch da auf dem.
Auf dem Basteltisch.
Den habt ihr jetzt auch schon öfters mal gesehen.
Wenn ich hier die Kamera angemacht habe, beim Basteln.
Der Switch an sich ist echt cool.
Das Problem dabei ist nur, also erst mal kurz, ich zeige euch mal die Features.
MikroTik sollte mich beide übrigens auch mal sponsern.
Du bekommst 8 Gigabit-Ports und 2 SFP-Plus-Ports.
SFP-Plus-Ports kannst du reinmachen.
1G, 2,5G, 5G und 10G.
Je nachdem, was du für ein Modul reinmachst.
Aber.
Warum ich den Switch aktuell noch nicht empfehlen würde, ist, weil die Firmware Hardcore suckt.
Und.
Ich glaube, es gibt bis heute noch keine Firmware.
Kein offizielles Firmware-Release.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit MikroTik los ist.
Ich meine, wo ist denn die Logik?
Ich release eine Hardware und ich habe noch keine Firmware dafür fertig.
Es hat einen Web-GUI.
Das ist das Switch OS.
Mal gucken, ob es eine Demo von Switch OS gibt.
Ich kann es nicht zeigen, weil ich habe es nicht an.
Ich kann das Web-GUI zeigen.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz anschalten, Leute.
So, ich zeige euch gleich das Web-Interface, wenn das Ding gebootet ist.
Also.
Es hat ein Web-Interface.
Kannst du auch über CLI konfigurieren.
Aber es ist halt unfertig.
Wenn man sich die Firmware anguckt.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob es jetzt mittlerweile was Neues gibt.
Sobald es eine wirklich releaste Firmware gibt, die keine großartigen Probleme mehr hat.
Dann kann ich es nicht anstellen.
Dann kann ich den Switch rein von der Hardware wirklich empfehlen.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass die Leute irgendwie in einen inoffiziellen Forum-Thread müssen.
Und sich dort dann irgendwelche komischen Beta-Firmwares runterladen müssen.
Ich finde übrigens den Thread mit der Firmware gar nicht.
CSS.
Ich weiß dann, was ich suchen muss und ich finde es noch nicht einmal.
Haben sie jetzt eine offizielle?
Nein, wenn sie jetzt eine offizielle Firmware haben, dann kann man sich das Ding tatsächlich kaufen.
Wo haben die das denn im Download?
Hier, SW, SwitchOS, CSS.
Nee.
Ach hier, da.
Ach guck mal, es gibt jetzt tatsächlich, es gibt eine Firmware.
Na, immerhin, immerhin.
So, ich gucke mal kurz nach.
Ich kann euch das Webinterface zeigen.
Muss es nur mal kurz raussuchen.
Wenn ich das finde.
Muss ich mal in mein DHCP gucken.
Mikrotik.
Der müsste es sein.
Ja, der müsste es sein.
So wie ich mich kenne, ist es Admin123456.
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt habe ich ein Problem.
Was habe ich da für ein Passwort genommen?
Das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr.
Was ist in der Standard-User bei Mikrotik?
Ist es Admin?
Admin no Passwort.
Ah, Admin no Passwort.
Easy.
Okay, ich habe gar kein Passwort vergeben.
Also, so sieht das Webinterface aus.
Ich mache mal kurz Darkreader raus.
Du kannst halt nicht allzu viel machen, aber du hast ein Managed Webinterface,
wo du so Sachen machen kannst, wie WLANs vergeben und Port Aggregation und sonstige Geschichten.
Aber wir müssen mal kurz Upgrade gucken.
System.
Oh, wir haben ein Firmware-Update.
Wo geht das?
Firmware-Update.
Das ist zu Big Brain.
Ich finde es noch nicht einmal.
Upgrade.
Hier, ich habe zwei Brings.
Latest Available Version.
Download and Upgrade.
Updaten wir das Ding jetzt.
Please do not interrupt.
Gleich haben wir den Switch geprickt.
Mal gucken, ob es halt anders aussieht.
Tja, also das könnte ich jetzt tatsächlich...
Also, wenn die Firmware released ist, ging auch relativ schnell.
Wenn die Firmware released ist und dir jetzt tatsächlich die meisten Probleme behebt,
dann kann ich dir empfehlen, weil wie gesagt, ihr bekommt zwei SF4 Plus Ports für 1, 2,5, 5 und 10G.
Ich habe da ein 10G-Modul drin und Kupfer-Ports 1G, 8 Stück.
Das ist preis-leistungsmäßig wirklich unschlagbar, weil das Ganze kostet, glaube ich, nur 85 Euro.
Ja, bla, das 10.
Hier müsst ihr gucken, ne?
85, 90 Euro.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Und du kannst hier schon ein bisschen advancede Sachen mitmachen.
Seht ihr?
Du kannst hier schon ein bisschen advancede Sachen mitmachen.
Du kannst Ports zusammenfassen zu...
Kannst ganz gut.
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwie 4 Gigabit-Ports zusammenfassen zu einem 4 Gigabit-Port.
Du kannst, ähm, was auch immer das sein soll.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer.
Tja, im Prinzip braucht man wahrscheinlich nur die WLAN-Settings.
Sonst nichts großartig.
Zumindest ist hier die WLAN-Config einfacher als unter RouterOS.
Die RouterOS-Einstellung für WLANs ist echt komplett Cancer.
SNMP, falls irgendwie einer SNMP-Monitoring daheim hat.
Ich glaube es ja eher nicht.
Tja, das war es.
Also es hält sich im Vergleich zu RouterOS durchaus in Grenzen, was das Ding kann.
Es ist halt ein Switch und es ist RouterOS Lite.
Aber für 85 Euro ist der Switch wirklich gut.
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Welchen Router hast du?
Also ich habe einen Hex-PoE.
So ein Teil.
6 Ports.
5 Ports Kupfer, 1 SFP-Port.
Kann man aber auch auf einen R45-Adapter reinmachen.
Der ist echt gut.
Das ist zum Beispiel ganz praktisch, dass der PoE hat.
Weil...
Ich habe meine 2 Access-Points dran, per PoE.
Ich habe hier 2 Unifi-Access-Points.
Du musst nur darauf gucken, dass das funktioniert.
Du musst den Router mit einem 48V Netzteil betreiben, sonst geht das nicht.
Weil das...
Die gleiche Spannung, mit der der Router betrieben wird, benutzt er für PoE.
Also die haben da keine großartigen Spannungswandler oder sowas drinne.
Also, wenn du beispielsweise Access-Points, die PoE brauchen, betreiben willst,
dann musst du halt an den Router einen 48V Netzteil anschließen.
Aber da gibt es genug von.
Ja.
Preis-Leistung ist beim MikroTip top.
Cisco ist halt benutzerfreundlicher.
Ja, Cisco ist halt benutzerfreundlicher, wenn man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat.
Und auch insgesamt ist das Handling doch angenehmer.
So, also.
Hatten wir.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Habe ich schon vorgelesen, aber 14 Monate ist Massive Hyper-Subscription.
Ja, die Shelleys sind richtig cool.
Vor allem, weil man den Kram nicht flashen muss.
Man kann den zwar flashen, aber...
Deswegen finde ich es nach wie vor richtig fail, dass Shelly als Domain Shelly.Cloud hat.
Das Hauptverkaufsargument von den Shelly-Dingern ist, ehrlich gesagt, ja...
Dass die nicht... dass die keine Cloud brauchen.
Aber, was auch immer. Big Brain... äh, Domain.
Berger Games, Twitch Prime Subscription.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge IQ Boost wieder hier.
So.
Das stimmt, wir haben einige stille Zuschauer, aber die sind regelmäßig am Start.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es immer geil, wenn ich teilweise Leute wieder subscriben sehe, die schon...
Irgendwie zwei Jahre oder so am Start sind oder länger.
Mobuntu heißt das.
Guck, wenn du dir das installieren willst, dann gehst du hier...
Mobuntu, suchste.
Und dann gehst du da hin und lädst dir das Theme runter.
Und dann hast du massive...
Obuntu-Theme.
Nein, habe ich noch nie installiert.
Preisjump ist bei Hetzner gehostet.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Leute, soll ich nochmal eine Runde Hetzner-Sellout machen?
Ja, komm, scheiß drauf. Hauptsache die Statistiken sehen gut aus.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal kurz eine Runde Hetzner-Sellout.
Wenn wir gerade schon mal dabei sind.
Falls ihr mein letztes Video nicht gesehen habt
und ihr mal
die Hetzner Cloud ausprobieren wollt,
da könnt ihr über den Link hier,
den ich jetzt gleich in den Chat poste,
könnt ihr hingehen und wenn ihr euch angemeldet habt,
könnt ihr dann in der Konsole, steht ja hier alles drinnen,
in der Cloud-Konsole, gebt ihr den Code ein
und dann bekommt ihr 20 Euro
Guthaben.
Und was man mal mit diesem 20 Euro Guthaben machen kann,
kann ich euch auch zeigen.
Ihr könnt euch zum Beispiel für 3 Monate lang
fast, fast
einen 3-Core, fast einen
Triple-Core-VM kaufen, oder
ihr könnt euch
zum Beispiel das Ding holen
für, ja, also
man kann da schon ein bisschen was mitmachen,
mit 20 Euro Startguthaben.
Ich meine, die kleinste VM kostet aktuell
3 Euro, das schwankt immer ein bisschen, je nach Tag,
aber
20 Euro ist zum Ausprobieren wirklich
top. Oh, guck mal, ich kann meinen
Link nicht kopieren. Was ist denn hier los? Warum kann
ich mein, warum darf ich meinen eigenen Link
nicht kopieren? Keck Wait.
Okay, dann kopiere ich den so.
Excellent. Könnt ihr draufklicken, könnt
euch einloggen. Geht allerdings,
wie gesagt, nur für Neukunden.
Also, wenn ihr da schon angemeldet
seid, dann müsst ihr euch überlegen, was er
macht.
Weiß ich nicht, ob die so erfreut sind über
zweite Codes, keine Ahnung. Soll mir
aber auch egal sein.
Da könnt ihr euch zumindest anmelden und in der
Cloud-Konsole den Kram einlösen. So, und da
hoste ich übrigens auch den Preis-Champ.
Wen das interessiert, der Preis-Champ, der läuft,
also das Ding,
der, oh, guck mal, Alternate
hat hier Exquisite
für einfach nur doppelten
UVP-Preis aktuell 3790.
Excellent.
Ein wahrer Schnapper.
Also der,
also der Preis-Champ,
der läuft aktuell mit
drei Stück davon,
einer davon
und einer
davon. Also es sind, es sind
insgesamt fünf VMs.
Das sind die Crawler, die die
Shops updaten, da sind es drei Stück.
Das hier ist aktuell das Frontend,
reicht eine Dual-Core-Kiste locker aus.
Und das hier ist so ein Analytics-Server,
der aber keine Benutzersachen
aufzeichnet, weil sonst DSGVO,
ihr wisst ja. So sieht's aus.
Also ich hab da ja auch nicht
so die Wahnsinns-Ausgaben
für. Am Anfang hatte ich eine super fette
16-Core-Kiste zum Testen,
aber das hat sich nicht gelohnt.
So.
Äh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Können wir mal ein Ausrufezeichen
äh,
BigBrainMod-Team am Start,
können wir einen
Ausrufezeichen-Hetzner-Command machen,
wo der Link drinsteht?
Warum braucht man da so viele VMs?
Äh, bietet sich an
in dem Fall. Eine fürs Frontend,
drei für die Crawler und eine Analytics-Kiste,
die man für alles andere auch verwenden kann.
Die kommen sich auch nicht in die Quere,
machen die Crawler beispielsweise nicht komplette CPUs,
die sind auch nicht zu dicht.
Vorher hatte ich's auf einer 16-Core-Kiste
mit, äh, Docker und, äh,
CPU-Beschränkungen laufen.
Das hat aber andere Probleme gemacht.
So.
Ich komm auch, glaub ich, nicht mehr zum Einkaufen.
Der Chat ist...
Massive Active.
Ich, ich benutze übrigens
Arch Linux, by the way.
Falls ihr's noch nicht mitgekriegt habt.
Oh Mist, jetzt hab ich das Blackfacing-Emote verwendet.
Anzeige ist raus. Toss.
Alter. Das hab ich ja immer noch im Board.
Keck Wait.
Das ist ja verpönt
mittlerweile.
Band.
Ja, genau.
Nein, die Lieferung bleibt nicht beim Zoll
hängen. Das ist das Gute
an den chinesischen China, äh,
China-Shops.
Die bleiben nicht im Zoll
hängen, weil die Chinesen machen das
richtig. Die schicken das entweder
über die Niederlande,
dann ist es von der EU nach EU,
also kein Problem, oder sie schicken
es über Spanien, dann ist es auch von EU
nach EU. Oder sie haben ein
Warenlager und schicken es gleich von EU
nach EU.
Das einzige, wo du Pech hast
mit dem Zoll ist, wenn du
den aller, aller, aller billigsten
Versandweg nimmst
und die China, Chinesen,
chinesischen Shops nicht
wissen, wie es geht
und es 48 Tage unterwegs
ist und irgendwie direkt an dich adressiert
mit dem Schiff kommt, dann lagen sie es
gleich beim Zoll. Aber sonst machen die Chinesen
das richtig und es landet eigentlich so gut
wie nie beim Zoll. Kann man das
anklicken oder ist das, ist das Rickrolled?
Ne. Das hatten wir
doch. Das
hatten wir doch, das hatten wir doch gestern.
Das hatten wir doch gestern.
Äh, du musst,
du musst beim Booten
Display
äh, Drive gleich Mesa
einstellen. Ja, warte mal, ich guck mal in meiner
History. Mesa?
Driver gleich Mesa musst du einstellen.
Beim Booten.
Da steht Driver gleich Free
und das musst du überschreiben mit Driver gleich Mesa
dann funktioniert's. Moment,
das hatten wir schon.
Äh, pfff, tja, ne, weiß
ich auch nicht. Vor allem bei Tools installieren auf jeden Fall, ne?
Also, vor allem bei
Workstation funktioniert in dem Fall auch deutlich besser
als VirtualBox. Und du musst
vor allem bei Tools installieren, inklusive der,
den ganzen X-Server-Gedöns.
Hast du Clipboard Manager laufen?
Ja, hab ich. Ich hab
ich habe
laufen
GreenClip, glaub ich.
GreenClip mit der RoFi-Extension.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist ganz praktisch, da kannst du das hier nämlich
auch durchsuchen, deine History.
Richtig Spock.
Ja, wenn du dann was aus der History brauchst,
aus deiner Clipboard-History, klickst
da an, kannst gleich einfügen. Eigentlich recht
nice.
Passwort-Leak. Oh, was hab ich wieder
geleakt, Leute? Wo hab ich mein Passwort
geleakt? Ist doch gar kein Passwort.
drin hier.
Chat.
Warum macht ihr sowas immer?
Warum gebetet ihr mich immer?
Der Chat, der Chat
macht es immer, wenn ich Critical Information
lecke. Was zum Teufel
sind Agilators?
Warum hab ich Agilators, bitteschön,
in der Clipboard-History?
Agilators.
Das hier ist btw. auch
ein Passwort, das sind irgendwelche kopierten
Zeichen, ja.
Okay. Ja, Mikrotik ist
ultra nice. Achtest du auf Kabeldurchmesser,
wenn du zum Beispiel LEDs an Netzteile
anschließt oder so?
Ja, mittlerweile schon.
Nachdem ich mir mal
fast die Finger verbrannt habe, im
Stream, falls sich da noch einer dran erinnern kann,
weil ich
ne 5V LED
Strip mit 10A betrieben hab,
mit nem Mini-Kabel
und...
Falls sich da noch einer dran erinnert.
Seitdem achte ich auf
Kabeldurchmesser, ja.
Hab ich schon gezeigt.
Was geht's hier um Sponsoring-Geschichten?
Zeig mal. Was ist hier
die Diskussion?
Achso, Mikrotik sponsort dich mal.
Ja, die sollen mich mal gefälligst
sponsoren beim Mikrotik.
Ich könnte ja Reverse
Sponsoring machen, also sprich,
anstatt dass Mikrotik mich anschreibt,
schreib ich einfach Mikrotik an,
mit nem schlechten
Übersetzer auf Polnisch.
Die kommen doch aus Polen, oder?
Kommen die nicht aus Polen, Mikrotik?
Lettland. Lettland.
Ach du Scheiße, was spricht man denn...
Was spricht man denn in Lettland?
Sprache.
Lettisch. Ach du große Scheiße.
Lettisch.
Okay, okay, ich muss mal kurz...
Google Translator
...
Also, also, wir probieren das jetzt mal kurz aus
German.
Deutsch.
Nach Lett.
Lettisch. Also, also.
Hallo Mikrotik.
Das klingt aber auch schon fast gekommandert.
Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr
mich sponsoren?
Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr mich
sponsoren?
sponsiern?
Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr mich
sponsern?
Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr
mich sponsern?
Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr mich
sponsern?
Hallo Mikrotik.
Hallo, na nee, P Imma,
neues I spoon.
Also, warum geht das denn
weiter?
Hey, hey, hey,
mich sponsoren klingt kann auch russisch sein kann ich ich bin triggert ich möchte gerne einen
weiblichen sprecher haben geht nicht oder wie kann ich wie kann ich die sprache ändern die
die stimme geht das alles klar und jetzt ganz wichtig wie klingt es auch französisch
ist das der arie musik nein das ist mario kart musik womit könnte ich denn gut wie
lands einrichten wenn die fritzbox kann so was
machen
ja zum beispiel mit so einem mikrotik switch oder mit jedem mit eigentlich mit fast jedem
etwas besseren switch hast du sind einem keeper snip aber es war ja gar kein passwort es war ja
einfach enter drücken der hat auch eine seele der switch ja glaube ich zumindest gute os hat
eine seele gute frage ob er auch eine seele hat eine seele 2 punkt hat eine seele normalerweise
sie hat eine seele dieder hat keine zieler der hat anscheinend nur web interface das
wusste ich auch nicht okay so web interface ziel als sprichman käleier man macht vieles
erinnert mich ankommt an die call of duty videos früher max da spricht man cobra aus und nicht was
für eine firewall benutzerober und beim zweiten mal hat idee als bundeswehr fahrzeug an guten tag
sind die, die in dem Router eingebaut ist.
Die Standard-IP-Filter-Firewall,
die im Hex-PoE drin ist.
What the fuck?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ja, ist sehr laut. Easy.
War das nicht so
ein ausgedienter
AZ-Switch, der
auch relativ laut ist und Stromverbrauch?
Ist er? Ja.
Kann sein. Fliegt an den Seiten.
Ja, sobald
der Crawler aktualisiert wird, schon.
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Magst du Katzen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen könnte.
Aber in Wirklichkeit,
in Wirklichkeit mag ich, mag ich
keine Katzen.
Ich hab zwar Katzen-Emotes, aber
ne. Doch, doch, klar.
Ich hab ja nicht umsonst eine.
Kann man Agile und Diagonal
skalieren?
In der Magenta-Cloud? Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Diagonal skalieren ist in der Magenta-Cloud
geht das nicht.
Diagonal skalieren kann man vielleicht
mit nem, mit nem, mit nem Stadia-Account
oder so, aber nicht in der Magenta-Cloud.
Das funktioniert nicht.
So, also. Kommen wir jetzt heute noch mal
irgendwann anfangen. Zeig mal her.
Schaust du eigentlich auch über die Shops Saturn im Media-Markt?
Äh, wenn's da was gibt?
Bist du auf Windows und Linux gleichzeitig? Korrekt.
Hier ist mein Windows, hier ist mein Linux.
Der ist wirklich praktisch.
Kann ich ja, ist auch easy zu installieren.
Okay.
Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich's
gleich alles.
Das kann ich dir sagen,
was du da machen musst.
Ich, ich, ich sollte, ich sollte
Consulting-Geld verwenden mittlerweile.
Du musst das hier installieren.
Äh, MM?
Wie, wie heißt das?
Wait, wait a minute.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ping?
Jetzt geht's. Okay.
Äh, das musst du installieren.
Und natürlich das
VMware-Zeug starten, aber du musst für
Clipboard musst du den Kram installieren.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal ein Update machen hier nebenbei,
wo wir grad dabei sind.
Exquisite Update.
Oh, ja, vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
So.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich das Katzen-E-Mode
so reinmach.
Weil Chico, so ein Chico-E-Mode bräuchte
man eigentlich schon. Und das hat er ja auch
ganz gut ausgeschnitten hier.
Ist Hetzner agil?
Agil genug.
Agile.
Hyper-Agile.
Die machen bestimmt auch viel Daily-Scrums und so.
Und haben ein Kanban-Board.
Da kann eigentlich nix mehr schiefgehen.
Wenn sie dann auch Save und Team-Shape Teams anwenden,
dann ist eigentlich alles in Butter.
So.
Gut, also, da können wir jetzt, ich bin im Chat durch,
da können wir jetzt mal anfangen einzukaufen, würd ich sagen.
Bam, in your face.
Also.
Wo hab ich meine massive Einkaufsliste?
Irgendwo hab ich die hier am Start.
Zeig's mal her.
By the way, äh, ich hab übrigens noch ne gute Idee.
Ich hab übrigens noch ne gute Idee,
das muss ich mal den Hetzner-Leuten
vorschlagen.
Weil es wird ja immer im Stream
gefragt, wie ich das mache,
dass ich Lokal-Zertifikate verwende.
Na, ihr habt's ja schon öfters gesehen,
wenn ich beispielsweise hier auf mein Dashboard gehe,
dann ist das, hat das ein gültiges
Zertifikat.
Und ich hab ja schon öfters erklärt, dass ich hab ne eigene
Domain, mach Let's Encrypts und sonst wie.
Ich hab mir gedacht, man könnte
echt mal nen Stream machen, wo man das
wirklich mit so wenig
Zwischenschritten und so wenig
Magic macht, wie geht.
Sodass man vielleicht mal versteht, wie der ganze
Kram funktioniert.
Also sprich, wir würden uns ne Domain machen,
wir würden, ähm,
dann
den DNS von Hand, den Key hinterlegen
und mit Certbot ein Zertifikat machen.
Das dauert jetzt zwar nicht lang, aber
dann sieht man wenigstens mal, wie das funktioniert
und was das macht. Weil wenn man so Sachen wie Traffic
verwendet oder irgendwelche fertigen Certbot-Skripts
oder sonst was, dann geht das zwar
auch alles, aber ist ultra Magic und keiner
versteht's.
Was für nen Notebook nutzt du bei der freien...
Ja, es gibt freie OS-Wahl, zumindest bisher.
Sie sind jetzt gerade so auf dem Trip, sie wollen
uns Windows vorschreiben.
Wo ich ja absolut kein Fan von bin.
Und wir haben auch lange genug gemeckert.
Das heißt, wir bekommen zumindest alle
weiterhin Linux-VM's.
Und, äh,
ich hab aktuell noch nen Manjaro
mit i3 installiert auf meinem Notebook und ich
bis mir das eine aus der Hand reißt,
werd ich das auch nicht, äh,
ändern.
Es sei denn, jemand schaltet es aus, nimmt's mir ab
oder sonst wie, der mir was zu sagen hat.
Oder gibt mir die Anweisung
explizit dazu, das nicht mehr zu verwenden und
äh, ich hab halt die Möglichkeit, was anderes
zu nehmen. Also, mal gucken.
Bei uns wird,
bei uns, ich weiß nicht, wie's bei euch auf der Arbeit
ist, aber bei uns wird
quasi immer ganz viel, ganz viel
Wind um nichts gemacht, ja.
Also dann soll das kommen,
ne Woche später soll das kommen, zwei Wochen
später soll das kommen. Und wenn du dann mal
nen Monat abwartest, kommt vielleicht von
zehn Sachen, die angekündigt werden, eins.
Also das Beste, was man bei uns auf
der Arbeit machen kann, ist in der Regel
einfach mal drei, vier Wochen warten,
wenn was Neues angekündigt wird,
oder wenn was Neues angekündigt wird oder angekündigt
wurde. Und, äh,
wenn es nach drei Wochen noch aktuell ist,
dann kann man sich da Gedanken drüber machen.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt.
Weil, die, die erzählen
so viel, wenn der Tag lang ist da, ist der
Wahnsinn.
Was ist denn das für ein Dashboard? Oh, ich glaub, das hab ich noch nie
gezeigt, das Dashboard. Soll ich, soll ich
vielleicht auch mal vorstellen, hier im Stream.
Ich glaub, Chat, das Dashboard
habt ihr noch nie gesehen, ne?
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wie auch immer
man das ausspricht.
Huge IQ Subscription.
WSLG probier ich vielleicht mal
sogar bei uns auf der Arbeit dann aus, wenn's
sobald, wenn ich nen Windows Notebook krieg.
Du dürftest
theoretisch auch TempleOS nehmen, wenn du damit ordentlich
arbeiten könntest, aber ich bezweifel's mal.
Unrundead Stufe 1.
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Ja, doch, gibt schon ein paar.
Mein Chef hat mir was zu sagen, mein Abteilungsleiter
hat mir was zu sagen.
Also, in dem Fall mein Teamleiter hat mir was zu sagen,
mein Abteilungsleiter hat mir was zu sagen, unser
Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Bereichsvorstand
oder so kommt als nächstes, glaub ich, hat mir was
zu sagen. Und
der Vorstand hat mir natürlich auch was zu sagen.
Also, doch, doch, da gibt's schon genug, die mir was
sagen können.
Ist das da auch so?
Okay, nice, okay, ich hab den Chat geschafft.
Auf geht's, also, exquisite
Attacke einkaufen hier.
Sarah Lombardi neues Album.
Wer zum...
ist Sarah Lombardi?
Die ist doch bestimmt noch in
der Castingshow, oder?
Na,
juckt mich auch ehrlich gesagt null.
So, also, Moment.
Was wollt ich denn jetzt einkaufen?
Ich muss mal meine Liste suchen, kurz.
Du wolltest
das Dash... Leute, das ist doch nur so...
Das ist doch nur ein Dashboard-Meme.
Ich zeig das Dashboard doch jedes Mal
jedes Mal im Stream
für meine Heizung, ja? Das ist ein Dashboard
für die Heizung, wo ich beispielsweise
sehe, dass meine Heizung gerade Wassertemperatur
hat von
54 Grad im Kessel, dass der
Brenner gerade aktiv ist,
Kesseltemperatur auf
48 Grad ist, das heißt, es heizt
gerade nicht, Abgastemperatur
unten ist, das heißt, es heizt gerade
nicht, aber was warm
ist, wird gerade gepumpt.
Das bedeutet wahrscheinlich irgendwie
Heizkörper an.
So, exzellent,
exzellent. So, wo hab ich denn jetzt
meine Einkaufsliste? Also,
wisst ihr, womit ich, das muss ich
euch jetzt mal kurz zeigen, wisst ihr, womit ich echt
liebäugle, mir was zu kaufen?
Ich, ich, ich, ich hadere
aber noch so ein bisschen mit mir.
Kennt ihr diesen Channel?
Der testet, der testet Staubsauger.
Der testet zum Beispiel
solche Dinger hier,
wo er irgendwie über den Boden,
über den Boden rollt und, und Zeugs
auf... Hallo, YouTube, please?
Vodafone?
Postjamp?
Vodafone, was ist da wieder los?
Droppen wir irgendwelche
Frames oder so?
Null Frames droppt.
Habe ich irgendwie großartige Auslastung
oder ist einfach die Verbindung zu Vodafone
gerade wieder, äh, die, die
Vodafone verb... Ah, jetzt geht's.
Okay.
Oh, ich habe noch Forever
laufen bei mir auf einem anderen Rechner, kann das sein?
Ja.
Ah, super.
So.
Also, der zeigt dann solche komischen Dinger und
der hat letztens was getestet.
Da, da bin ich am überlegen, ob ich mir sowas
kaufen soll. Wartet mal, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Da bin ich am überlegen,
ob ich mir sowas kaufen soll.
Weil das coole ist,
weil das coole ist,
das Ding ist quasi nochmal ein Staubsauger
für den Staubsauger. Also sprich,
der Staubsauger fährt rum,
fährt dann in die Basisstation und die Basisstation
saugt den Staubsauger aus.
Also da wird richtig viel gesackt.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, wenn er das zeigt.
Aber ich finde den Ansatz her,
der Staubsauger,
haben das nicht alle Sauger.
Nein, es gibt ganz wenige.
Es gibt ganz wenige, die sowas haben.
Das ist auch relativ neu.
Ja, also sprich,
das Ding...
Also das ist wohl ein guter...
Wo zeigt er das denn mit der Basisstation?
Das ist halt richtig nice.
Mit der Base.
Ja genau, hier fährt das Ding dann
drauf. Guck hier, hier.
Der ist jetzt fertig
sauber machen
und dann fährt er an die Dockingstation
und die Dockingstation hat hier oben drin
einen Müllbeutel und saugt den dann aus.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder?
Ich bin noch am überlegen,
ob ich mir das holen soll.
Das Problem ist, dass der Kram in Deutschland mal wieder übelst teuer ist.
Da braucht man ja doch wieder einen Beutel.
Was brauchst denn sonst?
Also ich meine, ob du jetzt
dies jedes mal ausleerst
und den Mülleimer schmeißt oder ob du
einmal im Monat den Beutel leer machst und den Mülleimer schmeißt, das ist mit dem Beutel doch
deutlich angenehmer, als es jedes Mal zu machen. Achso, du meinst, dass die quasi einen Mülleimer
machen.
Kann man den Flaschen, die leider noch nicht. Es gibt wohl irgendwie Trick 17, dass man den
zumindest mit Home Assistant betreiben kann, aber ich glaube, es gibt noch keine Möglichkeit,
ihn rein lokal zu steuern. Das ist ja auch das, was mich ehrlich gesagt davon abhält
bis jetzt. Also hätte, könnte ich den Flaschen oder könnte ich den rein lokal steuern, hätte
ich ihn mir schon gekauft, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock auf einen Cloud-Staubsauger.
Old version would be prone to hair clogs from my two cats, if I didn't run the robot at
least twice a week. If I ran it twice a week, the hair buildup wouldn't be so bad and it
would not rot.
Ja, ich, mal gucken, ob der noch was zeigt zur Basisstation. Ja, gut, dass das Ding wischen
kann, juckt mich nicht. Das kann meiner auch und das benutze ich nie. Ja, und das Problem
ist, dass der Scheiß halt viel zu teuer ist, für das, dass ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob
ich ihn wirklich haben will. Würde das jetzt 300 Euro kosten, hätte ich mir schon bestellt,
aber das ist übrigens der falsche. Das ist übrigens der falsche N8 Pro.
Ja, das geht dann eher, das geht dann eher so in Richtung 500 Euro. Ja, 600 Euro beim
Mediamarkt. Also ich denke mal, wenn man, wenn man was Gutes findet, bekommt man den
bestimmt auch für 500 Euro, aber 500 Euro für nicht genau wissen, ob ich den eigentlich
wirklich haben will, ist halt, ja, 600 oder gar 600 Euro ist halt Pains Champ. So teuer
ist der Aufpreis gar nicht.
Ja, auch, also wenn man sich andere anguckt, ohne das, also die richtig guten, da bezahlst
du auch 4, 450 Euro für. Warum ich mir diesen Staubsauger gekauft habe? Ja, eigentlich nur,
weil ich das Selbstlernen geil finde. Hier einen für 400, ha, lull, das ist bestimmt
ein Rickroll-Video, ha? Ne, ist kein Rickroll-Video. Wie gesagt, ich habe hier selbst einen, ich
habe einen Roborock S5, aber nicht den Max, den normal, also den S50, das ist der gleiche
S5. Den habe ich damals, glaube ich, für 290 oder so gekauft, aber da war der noch relativ
neu. Wie oft musst du sonst den Beutel leeren? Wie meinst du jetzt bei den aktuellen? Bei
den aktuellen musst du den nach jedem, also die haben ja keinen Beutel, die haben ja keinen
Beutel, die haben ja so ein Fach, was man rausnimmt. Das musst du nach jedem reinigen, das musst
du nach jedem reinigen, sauber machen. Und je nachdem, wie viel Dreck du hast, du musst
den vielleicht einmal im Monat machen oder vielleicht auch öfters den Beutel bei dem
mit Selbstleeren, ja. Naja, also wie gesagt, ich bin am überlegen. Sobald, sobald man diese
Dinger, sobald es einen guten gibt, den man rein lokal steuern kann, bin ich dabei. Easy.
Ist fortgekauft. Ja, das mit, da musst du dir mal das Video von dem Typ angucken, was
ich eben gezeigt habe. Der hat ja auch was explizit erzählt zu Haustierhaare. Hast du
keine Angst, dass die Chinesen den Raumplan von dir klauen? Ne.
Weil ich habe meinen geflasht. Guck hier da. Mein Staubsauger-Roboter sieht so aus. Hat
ein Webinterface, lässt sich komplett über das Webinterface steuern, dass das Wohnzimmer
liegt, ja. Aber keinerlei Connection mehr zur China-Chinesen-Cloud. Rein offline, wie
ich meinen Staubsauger verwenden kann. So muss das sein. So, also, jetzt aber, endlich
schon mal. Einkaufsliste. Ähm, ja, wie gesagt, weiß ich nicht, ob ich mir das Ganze kaufen
soll. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das Ganze kaufen soll. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das
Ganze kaufen soll. Chat, hat einer von euch so ein Ding? Hat einer von euch so ein Ding?
Das ist ein Lötkolben, das ist ein besonders kompakter Lötkolben, den man beispielsweise
über USB betreiben kann. Entweder direkt mit nem Quickcharge-Adapter oder über nem
Powerbank. Hast du eigentlich einen Discord? Ja, hab ich. Ich hab einen. Also, ich brauch
keinen. Aber ich finde die Idee hier, hier hinter ganz gut, dass du damit beispielsweise
auch, wenn ich mal was im Stall machen
muss oder hinten im Garten machen muss
oder irgendwie irgendwo mal ein Kabel, was halt
wo ich halt keinen Bock hab auf meine Lötstation
dann würde ich ne Powerbank
nehmen. Ne, das
ist das nicht USB?
Doch, doch, da ist das USB.
Der TS-80 ist mit diesem
ist mit nem Klinke-Stecker.
Warte mal. Moment.
Die Dinger haben doch
USB. Ernsthaft?
Ne, kannst
der TS-80 braucht aber dringend
Quick-Charge.
Moment.
Siehst du, da sind wir schon dabei.
Ich dachte, das geht über USB.
Ja, und wie betreibt man den dann?
Weil, ich mein, ich muss den ja an ne Powerbank
kriegen. Ah, Firefox
kaputt. Okay, excellent.
Wie? Hä?
Und wie ist das jetzt?
Ich dachte, da ist mit
USB, weil
ich fand die Idee halt gut.
Dass ich einfach ne Powerbank
nehmen kann und dann USB und
ab geht die Post, ja?
Und wie funktioniert jetzt hier die Stromversorgung?
Hat das nen Akku
drin? Ne, das ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Ach, hier. Ach, man braucht
nen 12-Volt-Ding.
Wie schließt man, gibt es?
Wie schließt man den denn dann an ne Powerbank an?
Weil, wenn ich da ein Netzteil für
brauch, dann ist es also ein richtiges Netzteil
für den Stecker, dann ist doch sinnlos, oder?
Powerbank.
Naja, gut, wie auch immer.
Ey, hat mich interessiert.
Ob den einer von euch hat, weil ich fand die Idee
von nem mobilen Lötkolben echt ganz nice.
Aber mit USB ist natürlich
dann schon praktischer, ne? Also, wenn
du, wenn du eine Powerbank anschließen kannst.
Powerbank hat doch nicht
genug Power für nen Lötkolben. Doch,
hat es. Du brauchst ne Powerbank mit
Quickcharge. Brauchst ne Powerbank
mit Quickcharge.
Also, normal geht
auch. Ich hab ja so nen ganz, ganz billigen
USB-Lötkolben. So nen ganz, ganz billigen.
Den hab ich mir eigentlich nur gekauft,
just for fun. So, so,
hier, das Teil hab ich mir mal gekauft.
Das ist so dermaßen scheiße. Ich hab's mir eigentlich
nur gekauft, weil ich wissen wollte, ob's funktioniert.
Das ist, Leute,
wenn ihr den schlechtesten Lötkolben aller Zeiten
haben wollt, dann kauft
den hier.
Ich mein, der funktioniert. Der funktioniert übrigens auch
über nen ganz normalen USB-Stecker.
Ja, also es funktioniert.
Es wird auch heiß genug, aber es ist
wirklich richtig scheiße.
Strom über Klinke, ja.
Also, letztendlich über USB,
aber hier dann darin haben sie über den
Klinkeanschluss gemacht. Aber es ist, es ist
fail. Also, das Ding ist wirklich mega, mega kacke.
Also, es funktioniert, aber
ich hab damit schon mal was gelötet.
Schon sogar ein paar Sachen, wo ich was
ganz kleines, kompaktes mal gebraucht hab. Aber
schön ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Gaslötkolben.
Tja, okay, ne, dann, dann, da werd ich das, da werd ich das
erstmal verwerfen, die Idee, wieder so
sowas zu kaufen.
Ich dachte mir, es ist vielleicht ganz nice,
so, so mobile Lötkolben am Start
zu haben, falls es mit der Powerbank geht.
Aber,
ah.
Na, die Powerbank ist danach, wenn, je nachdem
wie lange du lötest, ist sie danach logischerweise
leer, ja. Aber für, für
ein bisschen sollte das schon reichen.
Okay, manche sagen, man braucht einen Adapter, ist aber
nice. Saugroboter mit
400, ja, aber das Dumme ist, dass die meisten
davon nix traugen. Du brauchst ja einen guten
Staubsaugerroboter plus ne Absaugestation.
Der ist 80p.
Ah, okay.
Und der geht über, über USB.
Oder USB, wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Okay, muss ich,
mal gucken. Ne, ich kauf mir da jetzt nix.
Ne, ne.
Ich kauf, ich kauf mir nix.
Trau ich keine, keine gute Idee. Aber wo wir grad beim
Thema Löten sind, was ich mir kaufen wollte,
ich hab letztens
sowas hier gefunden.
Äh.
Ähm.
Halter. Na, was muss ich denn da suchen? Wie hieß das?
Hier, sowas. Ähm, sowas hab ich
letztens gesehen und ich glaube, das wär was echt
praktisches. Ich hab mir
ja mal vor ner Weile so ein billiges,
so ein billiges Set gekauft,
mit so Sachen, die du an Tisch klebst, äh,
klemmen kannst.
Also diese, diese Krokodilklemmen, die man
an Tisch machen kann, die sind aber richtig
scheiße, die ich mir da gekauft hab.
Die verwende ich nicht. Und, äh,
jetzt hab ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir mal sowas hier
äh, äh, holen soll.
Und, äh, das macht
nen ganz guten Eindruck. Also das macht nen recht stabilen
Eindruck von dem, wohin, wo steht's hier?
Äh, mit 1,5
Kilo. Ich mein, das Ding ist
nicht groß, ne. Das ist, ähm,
irgendwie 3,5 Kilo.
30, 30, also,
25 mal 25, wenn man
sich's irgendwie quadratisch vorstellen
will, ähm, und wiegt halt
1,5 Kilo. Also das ist schon
nicht, also
es ist nicht super schwer, aber es reicht.
Auf jeden Fall.
So. Also, ich weiß
nicht, ob ihr sowas am Start habt,
aber ich glaube, das
wird's, das, der wird's werden, ja.
Den hab ich letztens gesehen,
hab mir noch ein paar Sachen angeguckt zu,
das hat nen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Ich mein, es hat
kein, es hat kein Absaugung oder sonst was,
aber, pff, wozu,
ja. Mach's Fenster auf
danach. Ja.
Also, das, das wird's wahrscheinlich
werden. So, was ich dann noch
brauche ist,
weil ich mir da auch nicht ganz sicher bin, ob's
da was Gescheites gibt. Ich hab mittlerweile
so viele Micro-SD-Karten rum,
rumliegen. Gibt's da irgendwie
so nen Sammler
oder irgendwie so nen Behälter, der was
taugt?
Wobei, warte mal, das kann ich mir doch bestimmt 3D
drucken. Moment, das kann ich mir doch
da kann ich meinen 3D-Drucker mal für was Sinnvolles
verwenden. Ah, ich mein,
das muss ja nicht schön aussehen.
Okay, sowas gibt, das ist viel zu wenig.
Ich brauch was für 20 Micro-SD-Karten.
Ja, also im Prinzip sowas
hier. Okay, okay, das, Moment,
das, das, da gucken wir jetzt mal, was man 3D drucken könnte.
Micro-SD
Micro-SD-Mappe
soll ich suchen, okay.
Ja, ist da sowas hier?
Also mir reicht's,
wenn's nur Micro-SD ist. Ich brauch, ehrlich
gesagt, gar nichts anderes.
Oh, das ist ja Big Brain.
Oh, das ist cool,
das gefällt mir.
Das kann man jetzt...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die aktuell noch flashen kann.
Die aktuellen HD-Scenes.
Das, find ich, ist ne coole
Idee hier. Vor allem, es ist halt nur für
Micro-SD-Karten und es passt,
es passt ziemlich kompakt was rein.
Wisst ihr, was ich
dann immer nicht versteh, ne? Die Leute machen so
ein cooles Model und dann drucken sie es in der
schlechtmöglichsten Qualität aus
oder machen ein scheiß Foto von.
Also, wenn ich da ein Model reinstellen würde, würde ich
zumindest die Oberfläche noch ein bisschen nachbearbeiten,
dass es nicht so
Monarch-S-mäßig aussieht.
Aber die Idee finde ich doch
sehr nice.
Comments. Ne, das brauch ich
net. Das ist auch cool,
aber da sind auch wieder so viele Sachen
drin, die ich nicht brauche. Wobei, hier kann
ich mir doch ausdrucken, was ich will, ne?
Hier kann
ich mir doch ausdrucken, was ich will. Das sind Micro-SD-Karten.
Da könnte ich mir, da könnte ich mir im Prinzip
einfach
sechs solcher Micro-SD-Karten-
Behälter ausdrücken.
Brauchst halt genau passende Schraube
für. Also, ich glaube, Schrauben habe ich wirklich
mehr als genug hier.
Okay, das ist ne coole Sache.
Ich glaube, ich druck mir sowas aus.
Warum sollte ich sowas
kaufen? Da kann ich mein 3D-Drucker,
da kann ich mir ein bisschen Filament wieder
verschwenden. Die rausdrucken,
die rauszubekommen, sieht schwierig aus. Da hast du recht.
Moment, wo...
Fuck, jetzt hab ich so... Wo war denn das?
Kommt man da von unten dagegen drücken, wenn man
das rausgedingst hat?
Okay, wenn du einen sehr kleinen Finger hast,
kannst du da unten dagegen drücken.
Aber mit meinem Pepega...
Pepega-Peepo-Fett-Finger
komme ich da wahrscheinlich nicht dazwischen.
Zumal es auch relativ dick ist.
Hm...
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist aber eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Aber ich brauche halt nicht die normalen SD-Karten.
Ich habe außer für...
Lasst mal überlegen, wo habe ich noch normale SD-Karten?
Für den... Für die Kamera
und für den Audio-Recorder.
Aber beides verwende ich eigentlich
nicht regelmäßig.
Stimmt. Eigentlich könnte ich...
Das stimmt. Eigentlich könnte ich dieses Teil hier ausdrucken.
So ein... So ein Ding
ausdrucken einfach und gucken, ob es passt.
Und wenn es passt, druck ich den Rest aus.
Das ist ja gerade das Gute am 3D-Drucker.
Äh...
Was soll ich da unten tun?
Ne, aber ich habe auf Github, wenn auch nicht top aktuell,
habe ich Dot-Files
von mir.
Wenn der Browser mag.
By the way, hat dieses Projekt nicht ein schönes Logo?
Also ich finde, das ist immer noch das beste Github-Logo
von allen Github-Projekten.
Das Logo ist...
Das ist so billig, dass es schon wieder gut ist.
So, irgendwo habe ich hier meine Dot-Files
da.
Und da hast du auch den ganzen Kram
und da hast du unter anderem auch die...
E3-Config.
Aber die E3-Config
an sich reicht dir ja nicht, ne?
Also wenn du das haben willst, du brauchst die passende
Statusbar, aber da ist alles drin.
Ist alles, ist alles drin.
Also wenn du das klonst hast, dann sieht es mir auch nicht
so aus wie bei mir.
Bis auf ein paar Kleinigkeiten vielleicht.
Ah sorry, Shithub, ja natürlich.
So, also, das speichere ich mir mal.
Ich glaube, ich druck da mal einen aus später.
Moment, was habe ich denn da noch im Warenkorb?
Erstmal muss ich mal kurz
den Darkroom wieder ausmachen, sieht kacke aus.
Oh, Flashbang. Oh, meine Augen.
Ich sehe nichts.
Blinded.
Okay, das Case kann ich...
Wobei, gibt es die gerade?
Das Case kann man nicht genug haben. Ja, easy, lasse ich...
Oh, na doch, ist ja lieferbar.
Das lasse ich... Leute, das Case lasse ich nochmal drinnen.
Schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
So, next. Also, was brauchen wir
als nächstes?
Ich muss mal kurz abhaken.
Werte Handhaber, TS100 lohnt sich nicht.
Dann habe ich hier irgendwie noch einen AliExpress
Eintrag, was auch immer das ist. Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Okay.
Tja.
Ich habe aus irgendwelchen Gründen mir was
gebuchtmarkt von AliExpress,
aber der Link geht nicht mehr.
Ah, doch.
Ach, ja, da
wollte ich mir noch... Aber ich weiß nicht,
ob ich mir das bei AliExpress bestelle.
Ich habe mir
diese Thermostate gekauft zum Selbstflächen.
Ich wollte mir jetzt endlich nochmal einen
Vierer-Pack kaufen, weil ich meine Vierer-Pack
für 13 Euro kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Die Dinger sind wirklich
nice. Ich habe mir, wie gesagt,
ich habe mir ja eins hier gekauft, habe ich geflasht
mit einer Custom-Firmware von
von Github.
Äh, ne. Genau, hier.
Custom-Firmware haben wir geflasht.
Wieder.
Haben wir übrigens auch im Stream gemacht.
Hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Und jetzt verbraucht
das Ding deutlich weniger Batterie
als mit der offiziellen Firmware.
Die offizielle Firmware hält irgendwie nur zwei Monate
oder so.
Und mit der Firmware kann ich das
wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein Jahr oder so laufen lassen.
OTA-Flash. Ja, ja, man muss nichts
löten. Über Bluetooth
kann man flashen. Und
es hat ein paar Zusatzfunktionen. Also, also,
erstens kann man den
ordentlich kalibrieren, was man mit der originalen
Firmware auch nicht kann.
Man kann Batteriestand
Uhr noch anzeigen lassen auf dem
Ding. Ja, ja, flashen über
Bluetooth. Hast du das nicht
geprickt? Ne, das geht wieder.
Ich dachte erst, dass ich's geprickt hab,
weil ich mich nicht connecten konnte, aber
äh, ich hab mich dann, ich hab dann 50
mal connect gespammt und dann ging's wieder.
Offstream.
So, und
jetzt hab ich mir halt überlegt,
kaufen wir halt einfach nochmal nen 4er-Pack.
Ich mein, für 13, 13
Euro kannst du da nicht allzu viel verkehren.
Moment mal.
Für was krieg ich denn das gerade auf?
Bei, bei, bei Amazon.
Bei Amazon.
Alter, bei Amazon.
Haben die überhaupt nen Mehrfachpack?
10,80 Euro. Guck mal, hier krieg ich eins
für den Preis bei AliExpress.
Ähm, wie ich
da 4 für krieg.
Gibt's da irgendwie 3er-Pack oder so?
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Lustigerweise, wenn ich
auf Google, auf der, what the fuck?
Warum findet man das bei Amazon nicht?
Könnt ihr mir das mal erklären?
Warum hab ich das jetzt bei Amazon nicht
gefunden?
Und hier find ich's jetzt, wenn ich über
Google such,
nen 3er-Pack.
Wo ist da, wo ist da der Sinn?
Versteh ich nicht.
Brand Kaishenguan.
Alles klar.
So.
Ähm, aber, es kost auch,
guck mal, hier kosten 3,22
Euro und bei AliExpress
kosten einfach 4,13 Euro.
Ich bestell mir das bei den chinesischen
China-Shops.
So, bam, 4 Stück.
Shipping, AliExpress Standard.
Bam.
Okay, also, eins muss man ja sagen,
die Chinesen haben's mit, ähm, mit
Rechnen nicht so.
Weil 10 Tage Versand ist halt nicht
bis zum 10. Mai.
So, also, in den Einkaufskorb.
Bam.
Jaja, fortfahren. Gut.
Next.
Was hab ich als nächstes?
Das muss ich mal abhaken.
Moment, abhaken.
Abhaken.
Ja, kennt einer von euch
gutes doppelseitiges Klebeband?
Ich hab,
ich hab ein paar Sachen ausprobiert und,
ähm, irgendeiner meinte dann
das letzte Mal, ich glaub von der Arbeit noch,
irgendwie, Ultra-Geheimtipp wird auch für
Autos verwendet oder sonst was,
irgendwie 3M.
So, irgendwie
sowas hier hab ich,
hab ich mir gekauft. Das, das Ding.
So, aber das ist Kacke.
Das ist Megasack.
Ich hab das, ich hab das im Keller
an den, äh, an die,
an den Verteilerschrank gemacht
und hab dort
ein 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse dran geklebt
mit
nem ESP drinne
und das ist 3 Tage später abgefallen.
Also, das stell ich mir nicht unter
extra stark vor.
Ich hab das bisschen erwärmst.
Muss man das warm machen?
Wo steht das, dass man das warm machen muss?
Also, wie gesagt, das hat mich jetzt nicht so,
nicht so, äh, begeistert, ne?
Es fühlt sich extrem
bappisch an, aber es klebt.
Er hat beim Endricht geklebt.
Was nach, was soll ich suchen?
V, was? VHB?
Moment,
das ist das, das ist doch das gleiche hier, oder?
Ist das jetzt was anderes?
Sieht genau so aus,
wie das, was ich hab.
Ist das jetzt was anderes?
Okay, man muss draufdrücken, jaja.
Das ist doch genau das gleiche, das hatte ich doch eben schon.
Also, wie gesagt, das, vielleicht hab ich's
auch falsch verwendet, also ich mein, ich hab's an den,
ich hab's an den Schrank gemacht,
ich hab das 3D gedruckte Gehäuse genommen,
da irgendwie ne halbe Minute drangedrückt
und dann hab ich's hängen lassen und 3 Tage später
ist es abgefallen.
Ultra crap gewesen.
Sollte eigentlich nicht sein.
TESA extra strong.
Alter, TESA.
Ist gar nicht das, das es noch gibt.
TESA extra strong.
Universal.
Flex.
Da wird geflext.
Tja.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das was taugt, Leute.
Ich bräuchte halt mal was, aber
irgendwie nix,
nix gefunden.
Einfach dübeln.
Ja, dübel mal was
in den Verteilerschrank von der Seite
dran.
Excellent Idee.
Heißkleber. Du wirst lachen, das hab ich mir,
das hab ich mir überlegt.
Ich hab da unten im Keller gestanden,
ich hab da unten im Keller gestanden,
wo ich gesehen hab, dass es abgefallen ist
und ich war kurz davor Heißkleber zu holen.
Weil der Scheiß hält.
Ich mein, ich hab
mit dem Heißkleber auf ner Fensterbank
ein Raspberry Pi festgeklebt
und da klebt der jetzt schon seit über nem Jahr
und das juckt
das überhaupt nicht.
Also ich hab mir ne Kamera gebaut
hinten für nen Hof
mit nem Raspberry Pi Zero.
Den Raspberry Pi Zero hab ich
in nen großen Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt
und hab's wasserdicht
gemacht damit
und dann hab ich einfach
mit nem riesen Klumpen
Heißkleber
an die Fensterbank gepappt.
Und das ist seit über nem Jahr
Wind, Wetter,
Turm, Regen
juckt das nicht, das hält einfach.
Bombenfest auf der Fensterbank.
Also Heißkleber ist immer noch beste, Leute.
Wird der nicht zu warm?
Die Bedenken hatte ich auch am Anfang.
Es ist ja auch noch ein schwarzer Schrumpfschlauch
in dem der drin ist.
Ich hatte auch das Bedenken,
dass wenn da die Sonne drauf scheint
paar Stunden am Tag, dass der zu warm wird.
Aber nö, funktioniert.
Funktioniert.
Gibt's keine Probleme mit.
Also Heißkleber
ist echt eines der besten Erfindungen.
Ich Heißkleber mittlerweile auch unsinnig viel.
Einfach weil's funktioniert.
Ich mein nicht so viel wie die Chinesen,
die ihre Sachen quasi mit Heißkleber auffüllen.
Aber wenn ich irgendwo was dran machen will,
sei es jetzt Elektro-Zeug, wo ich am besten,
also was da noch in ein Gehäuse kommt,
einfach erstmal Heißkleber reingesprayt,
dran gepappt, hält. Easy.
Dann hake ich das mal ab.
Mir fällt hier auch nichts gescheites ein.
Übrigens, hat jemand von euch so ein Ding?
Hat jemand von euch so ein Teil?
Sag mal hier, was ist?
Link.
Kleben statt bohren bis zu 120 Kilo.
Oh, das klingt gut.
Kleben statt bohren.
120 Kilo.
Das ist aber auch nur,
je nachdem,
wenn du dir ganz große Fläche machst, oder?
Der Schrank ist aus Metall,
Magnet ans Gehäuse.
Das würde wahrscheinlich
sogar funktionieren.
Aber 120 Kilo
hält das Ding doch nur aus,
wenn du quasi irgendwie einen Meter lang
vollklebst, oder so.
120 Kilo ist halt die Frage,
auf welcher Fläche 120 Kilo.
120 Kilo über
Quadratmeter ist jetzt,
ach, pro Rolle.
Ja, keck weight.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Hat jemand von euch so ein Teil?
Gibt's doch bei Amazon.
Sagt mir nix über den Preis, der Preis ist unsinnig.
Ja, den will ich nicht bezahlen, ehrlich gesagt.
Hat jemand so ein Ding?
Ich find das von der Idee her ganz cool.
Das ist eine Uhr, die kannst du mit
beispielsweise mit Home Assistant oder
anderen Sachen, kannst du Custom Sachen drauf
anzeigen lassen.
Also kannst du zum Beispiel
Home Assistant Notifications drauf machen,
oder was auch immer.
Das macht keinen so richtigen Anwendungszweck für,
aber ich find, ich weiß, dass man theoretisch
sowas selbst bauen kann, aber ich find die Idee ganz cool.
Zumal die Verarbeitung auch
ganz gut aussieht, also besser wie ein selbst gedrucktes
Gehäuse und sowas, aber
der Preis ist halt lächerlich.
Der Preis ist halt absolut
lächerlich. Ich geb doch keine
200 Euro für sowas aus. Ich mein, da ist
wahrscheinlich auch nur ein ESP
8266 drin, oder sowas.
Irgend so billiges Chinesen Zeug.
Und dann halt
kein 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse, sondern irgendwas anderes.
Aber wofür brauchst du das?
Ich brauch das gar nicht.
Genau, ich find die Idee cool, aber der Preis ist zu teuer.
Wenn ich mir nur Sachen kaufen würde, die ich wirklich
brauch, dann würde ich hier
bei Wasser und Brot sitzen und
sonst nix machen.
Ja, der Scheiß ist viel zu teuer.
Suckt, Alter. Ich finde die Idee
von solchen Pixel-Dingern richtig cool,
ehrlich gesagt.
Aber...
Find ich alles viel zu teuer.
Das ist auch nice. Das halb ich doch hier grad auf, oder?
Oder ist das was anderes?
Was der Chat grade...
Pics Backpack.
Ach ja, hab ich's euch
auf Twitter eigentlich schon gezeigt, was mir
gestern oder so, oder vorgestern jemand gepostet hat?
Weil ich hier grad nen Rucksack
seh. Da hat einer Leute gepostet,
jemand in der Bahn gepostet,
mit nem Rucksack, wo Rare Parent
draufläuft. Das könnte sogar sowas hier in der
Richtung gewesen sein.
Guckt mal. Guckt mal.
Das ist nicht nice.
Das ist doch so ein Teil, oder?
Das ist doch so
ein Ding. Sowas brauch ich.
Ist der, ist der
das zufälligerweise sogar?
Ist, ist der das
zufälligerweise sogar?
Dieser Rucksack?
Ist das das?
Drei Vermeser hat funktioniert.
Das ist das, oder?
Nee, nee, das ist was anderes.
Nee, aber nee, nee, das ist das nicht.
Guck mal, das Handle.
Das Handle sieht komplett anders aus.
Das sieht anders aus.
China nachgebaut. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Was kostet sowas denn?
Was kostet so ein Spaß?
160 Euro, guck mal.
Bei dem anderen kostet die Uhr,
bei dem anderen kostet die Uhr schon so viel.
Pixo Backpack. Gibt's das?
Gibt's das, gibt's das in Deutschland
zu kaufen? Fragt mich, ob das
wasserdicht ist. Tja.
Guck mal, für 100 Euro.
Easy. Das ist nice.
Gibt's dafür gescheite
Firmware oder geht das nur mit der offiziellen App?
Kann man das, sag mal, kann man das
animieren?
Oder kann man da nur Bilder drauf anzeigen?
Animation.
Animated Pixel Art Backpack.
Boah, das ist cool, das brauch ich, ja.
Okay, aber,
aber, also ne Diskette,
ne Diskette als, als
Powerbank oder was das ist, das ist mir zu
Hipster.
Das ist mir zu Hipster. Das ist so
richtig ein Retro-Hipster-Style.
Aber die Idee mit dem, mit dem
Blinker fürs Fahrrad ist schon cool, oder?
AliExpress. Ne, ich
kauf mir jetzt nix bei AliExpress.
Oder ist bei AliExpress der...
Das könnte der sein bei
AliExpress, den der eine hatte. Doch, tatsächlich.
Guck mal.
Das sieht eher nach dem aus, was der, was der
Typ hatte im Video. Ja, ja.
Guck mal.
Das ist der, das ist der Rucksack. Guck mal.
Das sieht, das sieht, das sieht original so aus.
Guck mal, das ist der
AliExpress-Käufer hier.
Seht ihr? China-Chinesische,
Chinesische-Chinesen-Bestellung am
Start. Metawall.
Die China-Namen
sind immer so geil.
Metawall. Mall.
Metamall.
Die, die, diese, diese,
diese chinesischen angeblichen Markennamen,
das wirkt immer, als hat
einer random
aus nem englischen Wörterbuch einfach zwei Wörter
genommen und zusammen kopiert.
Aber den hier finde ich echt,
ich bin am überlegen, ob ich mir so ein Ding
kaufen, kaufen soll.
Einfach, die Sache ist halt,
es ist halt, es ist halt brutal unsinnig.
Ne? Aber es ist
irgendwie auch nice. Da konnte ich meinen Keks
als Pixelart hinten drauf machen.
Überlegt euch das doch mal.
Da könnte ich, da könnte ich einfach,
aber dann erkennt man mich ja.
Ich würde Gachi-Bass, Hyper-Gachi mache ich hinten drauf,
Leute. Hyper-Gachi.
Kommt da hinten auf den Rucksack.
Bisschen cringig ist das schon.
Ja, ist es,
gäbe ich dir recht, ja.
Kommt aber ein bisschen aufs Motiv an.
Gibt es dafür, ok.
Github, gibt es dafür ordentliche
Firmware? Erstmal flashen.
Erstmal flashen
das Ganze.
Anschein, anscheinend nicht.
Ah ne, wie heißt das Ding? Pix, Pixu.
Ne. Pix, Pixpu.
Ok, ok. Also damit kann man
CLI
Script Controlling
Pixu Devices.
Alter, ist das, ist
ist das, die Musik
klingt wie der Typ, ach
ach, das ist, ok.
Klingt ein bisschen wie dieser Dude,
kennt noch einer den Flöter von der Ubisoft
Präsentation? Das war der Beste.
Ubisoft Flutgeil.
Moment, war das
war das überhaupt Ubisoft?
Moment, war das?
Ach ne, das war gar nicht Ubisoft.
Der Flutgeil.
Ghost of Tsushima ist wer?
Sony? War das Sony?
Direkt Sony?
Oder von wem waren das
nochmal? Sucker Punch.
Ok, die haben das auf der, auf der
Playstation Pressekonferenz wahrscheinlich rausgekriegt.
Der Flöter hier, das war der Beste.
Beste E3 Präsentation überhaupt.
Ah, yes.
Vor allem, wenn ihr das dann
2 Stunden 15 anhören wollt.
Was laber ich, 2 Stunden 15?
2 Minuten 15, die anhören musst du, dann hast
du gedacht, Alter, wann geht's denn endlich los?
Komm, der ist doch voll dabei.
Der, der fiel, der fiel das richtig,
diese Flöte, ja?
Oh, oh. Jetzt will er's wissen.
Jetzt gibt er alles.
Gleich gibt's die nächste Lootbox
Unlocked, ey.
Die Flöte ist schepp.
Guck mal, die ist kaputt.
Die hat schon so wild geflöte,
dass das Ding schon gebogen ist.
Nodders, Leute.
Wo, wo
sind die Nodders im Chat?
Jetzt geht er ab. Jetzt,
Hyper-Gadget-Time.
Huge.
Oh, ich dachte, er ist fertig.
Yeah.
Nice.
Am wenigsten ist es mal was anderes.
Ich hab das Spiel überhaupt, ich hab das Spiel weder
gekauft, noch irgendwie
mir überhaupt angeguckt.
Ich glaube aber, das ist ganz gut geworden, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay,
jetzt ist die große Preisfrage,
kauf ich mir so einen Kack-Rucksack oder nicht?
Ich find die, wie lang
hält denn die Batterie davon?
Wie lang hält denn die Batterie von so einem Teil?
Picsou.
Moment, Picsou ist da.
Ich muss Backpack, Backpack suchen.
Äh.
Akku.
Kurztest.
Akkulaufzeit.
Fünf Minuten?
Wait a minute.
Ah ja, ich bin mit allem einverstanden.
Blablabla.
Ich brauch Akkulaufzeit.
Oder muss man dann eine Powerbank
oder muss man, was? 24 Stunden?
Ernsthaft? Oder muss man einfach eine Powerbank
reinmachen noch zusätzlich?
Ah, okay, okay, man muss eine
Powerbank drinnen anschließen, okay.
Stromversorgung, mindestens 2,4
Modernen Powerbanks, von denen
eine solche
nicht im Lieferumfang erhält. Na gut, das macht nix.
Und wie viel
Stromverbrauch?
Ja, 24 Stunden, das hängt ganz
entscheidend von der Powerbank ab.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass das 24 Stunden
an der Powerbank hält. Okay,
wie lange hält das mit einer Powerbank?
Ich meine, das sollte schon so einen Arbeitstag
halten. Einfach Windkraftanlage
auf den Kopf setzen.
Was haltet ihr von der Idee?
Ich laufe einfach zusätzlich noch mit so einer
Mühle rum
und lass das am Kopf
kreiseln.
Da steht 24 Stunden mit 5000 Milliampere.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Geht ja nix von 24 Stunden.
Genau so ein Hut ziehe ich
dann auf. Aber
gehen wir mal von aus, das hält, das
hält zumindest mal den Hin- und Rückweg
durch.
Ich finde die Idee mega nice.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Gehen wir mal in den Beschreibung gucken.
Fantastiko!
Natürlich ist das
Geldverschwendung.
Wobei ich mir halt nicht sicher bin,
ob ich den dann auch wirklich anziehe,
wenn ich ihn habe.
Weil ein bisschen cringe ist es ja schon.
Ach, der ist
von Girls, dann darf ich den ja gar nicht anziehen.
Außerdem, warum assumen die,
dass ich kein Girl bin? Was soll das?
Abmahnung ist raus.
Nee, ich kauf das nicht.
Ich book mir das mal.
Aber das ist zu schwachsinnig.
Das kauf ich mir nicht.
Das ist komplette Geldverschwendung.
Ich kauf mir an sich nicht viel,
aber manchmal lass ich mich
auch, lass sogar ich mich da
zu sinnloser Geldverschwendung
hinreißen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt Fahrrad fahren würde
und man damit wenigstens blinken könnte,
sowas wie hier einer geschrieben hat,
das wäre ja noch cool.
Aber ich fahr ja kein Fahrrad.
Zumindest nicht in Frankfurt.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Also hake ich das auch mal ab.
Das ist Schwachsinn, das kauf ich nicht.
Ich weiß, es weicht jetzt etwas vom Einkaufen ab.
Ich wollte euch noch was anderes zeigen.
Hier mal auf Fiverr.
Ich hab mich ein bisschen umgeguckt auf Fiverr.
Und ähm...
Moment, Flashbang.
Ich lass mir nen 3D-Keks machen.
Ich lass mir hier nen 3D-Keks machen
und dann mach ich dann hier
äh, 3D-Keks
VTuber, Alter.
Das Blöde ist,
ich kann mir unglaublich schlecht
vorstellen, wie die ganzen
Anime-Grill-Leute
hier
gutes Keks-3D-Model machen wollen.
Ich find die Idee
aber lustig.
Einer wird jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen,
ich find die Idee lustig.
Leider kann man sich anhand
dieser Models
außer, dass der Pedobear hier gleich
um die Ecke gelaufen...
What the fuck?
Kann man sich hier
also schlecht
einschätzen, wer
da was hinbekommt.
Ne? Also wenn man
2D ist nicht das Problem.
2D gibt's richtig gute Leute,
wenn man hier nach 2D-Sachen sucht.
Auch wenn das alles wieder
äußerst pedobearig ist, aber okay.
Wie sagt der Sbarro immer?
Die sind ja eigentlich 3000 Jahre alt.
Ich kenn mich da nicht so aus.
Aber so nen Keks sollten sie
noch hinbekommen.
Und dann gibt's demnächst Keks-VTubing,
Alter.
Das wär mega lustig, ja.
Wo ist der Sbarro, wenn man ihn braucht?
Das ist ne gute Frage. Hat mal einer was vom Sbarro
gehört in letzter Zeit?
Warum ist der Cute-Mod?
Vielleicht hat das ja geklappt
mit seinem, äh,
Lehramtsgrill.
Dann ist der Cute-Mod jetzt
erstmal weg. Dann sehen wir den
in nem halben Jahr erst wieder.
Oh, nicht.
Der Cute-Mod war kurz im Discord.
Na, da bin ich ja beruhigt, dann ist alles in Ordnung.
Gut, nein, so'n
Schwachsinn glaub ich immer nicht. Bam!
Weg. So.
Dann brauch ich noch, das ist jetzt aber
unspektakulär, ähm,
ich bin, ich bin am gucken,
ob es
Silikonkabel, oh, genau sowas!
Easy.
Sind das Silikonkabel?
Genau sowas brauch ich. Gut.
Hat's schon erledigt.
Das sind Silikonkabel, oder?
Sind das Silikonkabel?
Nee, das sind keine Silikonkabel.
Ich hätte gerne sowas
als Silikonkabel.
Ich hätte gerne sowas als Silikonkabel,
weil die so schön biegsam sind.
Die sind auch biegsamer als die normalen.
Sowas als Silikonkabel,
das wär pock.
Warum findet Amazon das eigentlich
unter Silikon? Wie viel ist denn da drauf?
40 Fuß.
Was sind denn 40 Fuß in Meter?
12 Meter, okay.
Das fleischt. Na gut.
Heißt sich ja nicht
flexibel. Okay, guck mal mal.
Flexibel.
Das ist alles nicht so das.
Die sind aber auch nicht flexibel.
Die Silikonkabel sind halt insofern ganz cool,
weil die super biegsam sind.
Weil die super biegsam sind.
Und ich hätte halt gerne so ein 4x4 Pin
schon komplett zusammen,
weil sowas hier kannst du halt auch easy als Sensorkabel verwenden.
Sensor dran
und
wenn du super ordentlich bist, machst du irgendwie so einen
Geflechtschlauch drum oder so. Braucht man ja eigentlich nicht.
Rechnen, Quickmuffs.
Und ich habe heute ein Video gesehen auf Youtube,
der hatte mega Big Brain Idee
und zwar, der hat
AJ
AJ11 Kabel genommen
für seine Sensoren.
Silikonkabel,
ja aber ich hätte gerne eins mit 4 drinnen.
Woodbite
mit 4 Kabeln.
Der hat für seine Sensoren
AJ11 Kabel genommen
und dann hatte der so einen
so einen Breakout Board
das fand ich richtig Big Brain
sowas hier in der Richtung.
Nur nicht so teuer.
Das fand ich äußerst nice
die Idee.
Der hat an seine Sensoren dann quasi AJ45
Stecker gemacht
und hatte dann so einen Breakout Board
an seinem Controller.
Das heißt du hast kein rumgefuddeln
mehr mit irgendwelchen Pins.
Du kannst außen an deinem Gehäuse einfach
einen Stecker mit Clips machen
und innen greifst du es ab.
Wahrscheinlich tut es da jeder.
Das ist ja der AJ45 Stecker oder?
Sowas hier im Endeffekt.
Das machst du ins Gehäuse rein
und hinten greifst du ganz normal
plus minus
und theoretisch zweimal
Data ab.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Geht natürlich nur wenn du die andere Seite
auch selbst designst.
Sonst funktioniert es natürlich nicht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser als irgendwelche
fest verlöteten Kabel
die du dann im Zweifelsfall
wieder ablöten musst im Keller
Aber glaube ich nicht
dass ich mir sowas kaufe jetzt erstmal.
Aber ich fand die Idee nur ziemlich gut.
Der Chat findet hier wieder
die ganzen Sachen.
Chat kennt sich aus.
Das macht aber einen ziemlich starren
Eindruck für Silikon oder?
Aber genau sowas suche ich.
Allerdings
waren wir beschrieben
die Wartezeit entspricht
meiner Erwartung.
Die sind ganz schön dünn.
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß auch nicht
warum die den Kram nicht einfach mal schaft
fotografieren konnten.
Aber für Sensoren reichen die auf jeden Fall aus.
Meine Sensoren sind 3,3 Volt, 5 Volt
und ein paar Milliampere.
Dafür reicht ja im Endeffekt
gibt es ja eigentlich fast nichts was dafür nicht reicht.
Kannst du wahrscheinlich mit einem Haar
verbinden oder so.
Aber sowas, aber ich mag Silikon
Kabel weil die halt so super
elastisch sind.
Hier gibt es noch mehr.
Aber Leute, die Dinger sind doch im Leben nicht
Das sind doch
stinknormale Kabel.
Das sind
stinknormale Kabel, wo einer
eine Silikonhülle drum gemacht hat, oder?
Die sind auch nicht flexibler als alles
andere.
Sieht zumindest nicht so aus.
Aber Moment, das Kabel ist sehr flexibel.
Das Kabel ist sehr flexibel.
Genau sowas suche ich.
Teuer, aber es gibt keine Alternative.
Erstmal
50 Meter für
50 Milliarden Euro.
Was ist denn Kacke zum abisolieren, echt?
Kann man nicht einfach abschneiden?
Im Zweifelsfall, wenn es gar nicht geht, nimmst du halt
ein Teppichmesser.
Hätte ich jetzt gedacht.
Nehmen das gibt keine Probleme.
Okay, Chat.
Das ist so klein, da erkenne ich überhaupt nicht was das sein soll.
Ja bitte
noch ein bisschen größere Fotos
machen.
Ich brauche das um Sensoren zu verbinden.
Ich will da nicht
irgendwie neue Hausverkabelung
machen.
Ich brauche auch nichts für außen.
Das ist alles overkill.
Ich brauche was flexibles,
wo ich Sensoren mit 3,3 oder
5 Volt und ein paar Milliampere verbinden kann.
Ach, die gehen etwas
zu leicht. Ah, verstehe.
Geschirmtes Erdkabel.
Ja, für so
irgendeinen ESP-Sensor.
Erstmal das fetteste Kabel überhaupt
rausholen.
Naja gut, okay, also keine Ahnung. Aber die...
Ich mag Silikonkabel.
Ich brauche ein agiles Kabel,
korrekt. Und ihr kennt
mich ja, ich bin die letzten Streams
schon am überlegen.
Einfach Jumperkabel.
Silikonkabel sind ein bisschen flexibler.
Und Jumperkabel sind
kurz.
Und meistens hängen sie nicht zusammen
und sind einzeln. Es gibt da ziemliches Rumgefrickel.
Aber man kann natürlich langes,
eine Rolle Jumperkabel nehmen, die zusammenhängen.
Das geht. Am besten halt mit Silikon.
Ja, und davon halt vier Stück
zusammen.
Weißt du, du willst den Sensor irgendwie
dran kleben und dann so 50 bis 100
Zentimeter zum ESP legen. Ja, zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel. Ja, zum Beispiel
den Sensor zum Stromzähler
zählen, an den Stromzähler pappen und der
ESP liegt dann unten im Schrank. So.
So nach dem Motto.
Kein Ding. Der Chat ist
hier schon wieder am posten.
Was haben wir hier?
Ach. Ja, sowas.
Okay, Leute, ich hätte jetzt noch...
Okay, also ich bin jetzt...
Ich weiß, ich wäre jetzt ziemlich wählerisch.
Ähm...
Gibt es das vielleicht auch noch in unterschiedlichen Farben?
Ja, das ist ziemlich
dünn. Aber für die Sensoren reicht das.
Das reicht.
Über solche Kabel,
über solche Mini-Kabel,
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
So die richtig ganz kleinen Furzkabel,
über diese ganz normalen kleinen Jumperkabel
hab ich Weihnachtsbeleuchtung
gemacht. Fünf Volt.
Ich glaub acht Ampere. War nicht
zehn, weil mehr das Netzteil nicht konnte.
Fünf Volt, acht Ampere über das Kabel.
Ich hab mir ein bissl den Finger verbrannt.
Und die Kabel waren
äußerst flexibel, muss ich sagen.
Bei der Temperatur.
Die waren äußerst flexibel.
Die werden halt
kurz, die waren halt kurz vorm Schmelzen.
Äh, nimm einfach ein altes
USB-Kabel. Genauso mach ich das aktuell.
Ich hab ein altes USB-Kabel
genommen, hab's auf beiden Seiten abgemacht
und Sensor dran gemacht.
Welche Niedlungsliste?
So das ist mal ein Jaro mit E3 WM.
Haben wir noch
Moment, haben wir noch den Stream, wo ich
den Finger verbrannt hab?
Den finde ich schnell oder gar nicht.
LED?
Pimp mal Weihnachtsbaum.
Das müsste er sein.
RGB LED Leiste?
Ich glaub
hier hab ich mir den Finger verbrannt.
24.11.
Also merkt ihr euch mal hier.
24.11. oder
12.
Ups, falsches Jahr.
24.11.
Ja.
Ja, ich glaub hier hab ich mir den Finger verbrannt.
Nur für Sensoren ist das hier
zu empfehlen.
Oh ja, das ist cool. Genau so was sucht...
What the f...
Was hat das jetzt gemacht?
Was hab ich denn jetzt hier
getippt?
Von KS?
Äh, Moment.
Ja.
Ja, so was ist ganz gut.
Wie viel Kabel sind denn da drinne?
20 Stück oder wie?
Aber sonderlich flexibel ist das nett, oder?
Das sind 4.
Das sind 4?
What the f...
Ich seh da mindestens 8 verschiedene.
Und wie flexibel ist das?
Oder woher weiß man, dass das jetzt flexibel ist?
Hohe Anzahl...
Trocken, feucht,
gelegentlich bewegt.
Was?
L-I-Y-Y ist hochflexibel.
Okay.
Das speicher ich mir mal.
Oh, 5 Schm...
5 Schm...
Gibt's das vielleicht auch kürzer?
Das Bild ist richtig gebatet.
Okay, Moment.
Lass mal schnell gucken, wo hab ich den Finger verbrannt.
Also erstmal...
Also erstmal höhere Auflösung.
Ja, ich war nämlich so blöd in dem Stream
und hab hier vorne
über diese Jumperkabel
hab ich...
Klick mal auf meinen Link, zeig mal her.
Die Jumper...
Über diese Jumperkabel hab ich dann gedacht,
mach ich 5 Volt, 8 Ampere.
Das war zu viel.
Hätte das gedacht.
Ja, sowas genau.
Sowas in der Richtung.
4 Polig, 5 Meter, ja.
Das ist ja richtig günstig.
Besser als bei
Amazon.
1,99.
Ich probier das mal aus.
Ob das wirklich so flexibel ist,
wie ich's gerne hätte.
Also, passt mal auf.
Ich muss mal schnell gucken, ob ich das finde.
Also, was kann das Netzteil?
Ich glaub, es waren 5 Volt,
8 Ampere.
Das Netzteil.
RIP.
Die scheiß chinesen Spannungswandler
haben hier 3...
Ne, 2 dieser Boards gegrillt.
So, Moment.
Wo verbrennt er sich die Finger?
Hab ich mir schon die Finger verbrannt?
Weil ich grade gucke,
ob es warm wird.
Ach, Moment, Moment.
Aktuell hängt ja noch gar nichts dran.
Warum sollte das warm werden?
Wo verbrenn ich mir die Finger?
Ich find's net.
Hier, hier.
Genau, jetzt schließ ich's an
und dann verbrenn ich mir die Finger.
Oh, Google Docs, please.
Okay.
Genau, da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Guck mal.
Über diese kleinen Mini-Jumper-Kabel
mach ich...
Ich glaub, es sind 5 Volt, 8 Ampere.
Dafür ist es halt null ausgelegt.
Auch diese Zwischenstecker nicht.
40 Watt mit Jumper-Kabel.
Can't wait.
Hast du bestimmt
du zahle Uhrzeiten.
Meistens abends, aber so richtig im Streaming.
Jetzt geht's noch.
Ich muss es voll auf weiß stellen,
bis es richtig warm wird.
WLED limitiert auch den Strom.
Ja, nee, nee, nee.
Nur wenn du die Limitierung einschaltest.
Ich hab die Limitierung ausgeschaltet.
Kannst nämlich explizit das Häkchen setzen,
dass WLED nix berechnet,
sondern einfach volle Pulle macht.
Oh, jetzt hab...
Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich mir gerade den Finger verbrannt.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Warte mal, warte mal.
1,56.
Moment.
Was hab ich da jetzt auf?
YouTube, please.
Come on.
Dann halt nicht.
Dann gucken wir's uns jetzt nicht an.
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Schlaft's jetzt runter, easy.
Nee, da hab ich keinen Platz für.
Leute, ich pfeif doch fest
platztechnisch auf dem letzten Loch.
Ich hab nur noch 10G frei.
Egal, egal.
Ich glaub, ich hab mir da an der Stelle
den Finger verbrannt,
aber das ist ja...
Anderer Browser?
Nee, das hat wahrscheinlich mit dem Browser
überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Guck mal, ich kann ja auch anonym machen
und so tun als ob.
Da sagt er, nope, darfste nicht.
Wird nicht
Browsermäßig gemacht,
sondern wahrscheinlich pro Video
und wenn's so oft abgespielt wurde.
Aber ist halt schon ein bisschen Monarch-es, das Ganze.
Und ich bin ja immer noch am überlegen,
ob ich das Geld für so einen
Schraubendreher-Satz
ausgeben soll.
Ich war da, glaub ich,
in jedem Stream
bisher drauf.
Und ich hab's mir noch nicht gekauft.
Ich bin immer noch am überlegen.
Eigentlich hätt ich's ja gerne.
Aber ich hab eigentlich
auf der anderen Seite auch welche,
die sind vollkommen okay.
Das ist zwar kein
wehrer Satz,
aber die sind in Ordnung.
Und warum sollte ich mir was kaufen,
also zu dem Hetzner-Sponsoring
bräuchte ich definitiv noch einen MikroTik
und einen Wera-Sponsoring, soviel wie ich Werbung für die mach.
Dann doch lieber eine neue Platte.
Brauch ich auch nicht.
Ich hab ja ne 8TB-Platte drin,
die hab ich nur unmountet, wenn ich streame,
dass ich nicht aus Versehen was leake.
Wer war beim Leak des Recording-Folders
alles dabei?
Also so
unwahrscheinlich ist das gar nicht,
dass man aus Versehen Sachen leakt,
die man nicht leaken will.
Das hat sich der Chat natürlich gemerkt,
das ist mir auch klar.
Man hat ja eigentlich gar nichts gesehen.
Man hat eigentlich gar nichts gesehen,
aber man weiß ja nie, wie Twitch-Policy ist.
Ich hab's lieber gelöscht,
das Wort.
Ne, gibt's keine Clips,
und wenn's Clips gibt, lösch ich die Clips,
weil eventuell Toss.
Warum ist denn der so lahm gerade?
Ja, Install, auf,
gib alles.
Kann ich andere Videos abspielen?
Ne, darf man nicht, okay, 0.
Ja.
Weißt du was, Leute,
ich hab heute noch nichts Teures gekauft.
Ich hab noch nichts
Teures gekauft, ich kauf mir so ein Teil.
Also ich mein, ich bestell's eh nicht on-stream,
weil ich mich einloggen kann, aber scheiß drauf.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit am überlegen,
mir das zu kaufen, ne,
aber ich sag immer jedes Mal,
ne, lohnt sich nicht,
ich hab ja was, und sonst wie,
und dann guck ich das nächste Mal wieder,
weil ich bin schon seit nem Jahr
oder so am gucken nach diesem Set,
ich bin immer wieder kurz davor,
mir das zu kaufen, lass es dann bleiben.
Mal gucken, ob das überhaupt das richtige Set ist,
wartet mal kurz.
Ist das überhaupt das richtige Set?
Was haben wir da dabei?
25 Stück, und wir haben,
also was haben wir,
Kreuz, gut, braucht man selten,
aber gibt noch genug,
Kreuz,
Schlitz, äh, umgedreht,
Kreuz gibt's genug, äh,
Schlitz gibt's relativ wenig nur noch,
aber, gibt's halt noch welche.
Der Schlitz kann man zum
Hebeln, genau, so, dann hat man
was zum Geier,
was da vorne ist jetzt, Torx?
Das nächste ist
Torx, oder?
Was ist das?
Das brauch ich net, Leute.
Das Grüne, das brauch
ich nicht, das Set. Da sind, da sind,
da sind zu viele Sachen drin, die ich, die ich nie
im Leben, die ich nie im Leben hab.
Was ist das? Auch so
Gedöns. Moment,
kann das sein, dass das da gar nicht alles drin ist?
Was heißt denn hier, Kreuz, Schlitz,
Schlitz, Schlitz, Schlitz, Torx?
Jetzt übertreiben
sie es aber.
Warum, hä, warum die gelben?
Die gelben Bavära sind ja da, wo man
mit dem Hammer hinten draufhauen kann,
aber was ist denn das für eine Kombination?
Feinmechanik und
mit dem Hammer hinten draufhauen?
Das ist aber ne äußerst
komische, äh,
ne, die Elektriker-Sachen sind eigentlich
rot und gelb.
Achso, das
sind tatsächlich die Elektriker, warum, okay,
dann ist die, dann ist die Farbgebung
nicht ganz einheitlich.
Weil ansonsten sind die Elektriker-Sachen immer
rot und gelb, und gelb sind,
sind diese Dinger zum hinten draufhauen.
Na gut, vielleicht war
einfach kein Platz für rot und gelb.
Ach, 673 Euro,
easy, ist ja,
ist ja überhaupt kein Problem.
Man kann's,
man kann's, man kann es ein wenig
übertreiben. Das Set ist übrigens nice,
das hab ich, ne, das hab ich, ich hab ein anderes.
Ist auch wurscht, geh fort, ich geb sonst wieder
zu viel Geld aus.
Ich geb sonst zu viel Geld aus.
Weg. Ne, das hat keinen Sinn
mit Bithalter, das hab ich ja schon alles.
Ehrlich gesagt,
das wird mir reichen.
Das wird mir wahrscheinlich voll und ganz ausreichen,
ne? 23 Euro
kann man aber machen.
Geh auf apple.com.
Warum?
Du meinst, wenn ich,
du meinst, wenn ich teure Preise sehen will,
ja, dann geh ich auf apple.com.
Apple.com ist geil.
iMac, say hello.
Will aber kein iMac.
Die Webseite ist broken.
Die Webseite ist rip.
Also das reicht mir, ich glaub,
das bestell ich mal, easy.
Ich mach hier immer den Fehler,
ich kauf mir eigentlich immer zu viel
von dem Zeug. Also wenn ich mich dann dazu entschieden hab,
dass ich mir das kaufe, kaufe ich mir meistens
immer zu viel. Genauso wie,
wenn ich mir teilweise
irgendwie,
was wollt ihr, nicht 4, Schwachsinn,
ein 5er oder ein 10er Pack von irgendwelchen
Controllern brauch, obwohl ich eigentlich nur 1 brauch.
Also eigentlich würde ein 3er Pack voll und ganz reichen.
1er kauf ich nie, wisst ihr ja.
Ich kauf nie einzelne Sachen.
Weil gerade bei Elektronik-Sachen und bei
Bastler-Kram geht dir immer ganz schnell
eins kaputt und dann musst du wieder warten.
3er reichen eigentlich in der Regel
und ich kauf dann meistens immer 5er oder 10er.
Total hängengeblieben. Ich hab so viel unsinnigen
Scheiß hier, den ich überhaupt nicht brauche.
Also, ja.
3er Pack Controller, ja.
Immer. Eigentlich ist das Beste
beispielsweise sowas hier zu kaufen.
Aber das braucht ein 3er Pack. Einfach ein 3er Pack.
Fertig. Kein 5er,
kein 10er, einfach ein 3er Pack.
3er Pack ist eigentlich am besten.
Also, was ist hier?
Ich bin zwar berufstätiger Mediengestalter.
Oh, kannst du gute Youtube-Thumbnails machen?
Ich such da Leute gerade.
Warte mal.
Ich bin kurz davor
ein Fach Informatik
auszubilden zu machen, nur um hier mitreden zu können.
Wenn ich in einer zukünftigen Vorstellungszone mal gefragt werde,
ob ich da bin. Ja, da hast du vielleicht Glück.
Da hast du vielleicht Glück
und du hast auch Leute, die hier gucken
und du machst Bonuspunkte.
Okay, mal schauen, ob ich irgendwelche
Questions übersehen hab. Müssen wir mal schauen.
Also,
KDE hat Wobbly Windows.
Tatsächlich, ja.
Ich weiß.
Das habe ich alles schon beantwortet.
Gibt es für die Storage-Boxen
auch ein CLI-Tool?
Ich würde fast vermuten, man
kann tatsächlich mit dem...
Du meinst das Hetzner CLI-Tool, ne?
H-Cloud?
Äh...
Ich würde vermuten, man kann damit auch
Storage-Server erstellen.
Okay, man kann zum Beispiel mit Ceph
erstellen.
Ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich nicht. Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Kannst Volumes anlegen?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
So.
Schauen wir mal hier. Questions.
Zack.
Hat man da Gigabit-Uplink?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, auf was sich das bezieht.
Das ist 2 Stunden her. 0 W.
Warum nur für Neukunden? Das weiß ich nicht.
Das...
Das haben die so entschieden.
Ich vermute mal, weil sie halt Neukunden
gewinnen wollen, hauptsächlich, ne?
Wenn du schon einen Account hast und da 400 Euro im Monat
bezahlst, dann sollst du das ja auch
gefälligst weitermachen.
Kannst du die Vodafone-Station empfehlen?
Ich kenne die Vodafone-Station nicht, aber ich kann in der Regel
äh...
selten Provider-Routers empfehlen.
Die Fritz-Boxen sind allerdings ganz okay,
aber die Unity-Media-Box
war kacke und die Vodafone-Box ist auch
kacke.
Am besten ist, man benutzt die Fritz-Box
für DECT und VoIP und solche Sachen
und ähm...
ein bisschen ordentlichen Router plus ein paar ordentliche Access-Points
für die anderen Sachen und dann ist gut.
Kostet ein bisschen mehr, aber
hat man auch mehr davon.
Okay, das habe ich schon alles beantwortet.
Das habe ich schon alles beantwortet
hier.
Okay.
Nein, habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Der Chat macht da wieder unsinnige Sachen mit, wenn die
irgendeine Dom... Also wenn der Chat
irgendwelche DNS-Einträge machen könnte
für eine Domain, dann hätten wir
hätten wir gleich irgendwie
Jepcock
Subdomain oder sowas am Start.
Leko,
8 Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Big Brain Subscription.
Tja, hartes Los.
Habe ich schon gesehen.
Hatte ich schon beantwortet.
Wieso
saugst du nicht andere Räume?
Naja, das Ding steht hauptsächlich im Wohnzimmer,
um den fetten Teppich zu saugen.
Also da liegt ein relativ hoher
und Staubfänger-Teppich
und ich verwende den aber auch für andere Räume.
Aber die Map resettet sich
ab und zu, wenn man den hoch
nimmt und umstellt
und ich lasse ihn hauptsächlich im Wohnzimmer laufen.
Ich lasse ihn aber auch in anderen Räumen im ersten Stock laufen.
Und er ist bis jetzt
noch nicht die Treppe runtergefallen.
Habe ich.
Hatten wir uns schon angeguckt.
Hatten wir uns auch schon angeguckt.
Wie bezahlst du bei AliExpress?
Äh...
Ich bin mir gar nicht
mal sicher, wie ich
das letzte Mal bezahlt habe.
Das hängt ja bei AliExpress immer ein bisschen
vom Anbieter ab, was die akzeptieren.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass es Anbieter gibt, die Paypal
akzeptieren.
Achso, geht das nicht mehr oder was?
Doch.
Genau, das kommt nämlich bei AliExpress
immer ein bisschen vom Händler ab.
Das heißt im Zweifelsfall
musst du mal gucken, ob es das Produkt
bei einem anderen Händler gibt, der Paypal akzeptiert.
Ansonsten Kreditkarte oder
ich habe auch noch einen AliPay Account.
Ich habe...
Also es war Boomer Story auszupacken.
Ich benutze den Kram ja schon eine Weile.
Ich benutze den schon so lange, wo man noch mit
AliPay bezahlen musste oder bezahlen
konnte oder dazu angehalten wurde, mit
AliPay zu bezahlen und AliPay
noch komplett auf Chinesisch war.
Da musste ich AliPay über den Google
Translator übersetzen, dass ich
wusste, wo ich was eintragen muss.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Deswegen habe ich
ihn mir auch nicht bestellt.
Locker. Wie gesagt, so
mache ich das ja gerade.
Ja, ich habe auch noch einen iFixit.
Also deswegen, eigentlich brauche ich das ganze Zeug gar nicht.
Wofür benutzt du die
ESP-Boards denn? Boah, ich habe total
viele Sachen. Also das letzte, was ich gemacht habe,
ist, wo wir auch im Stream ein bisschen programmiert haben,
war einmal für den Stromzähler im Keller
und
das nächste war für
das...
Was habe ich jetzt im Bad hängen?
Für Bluetooth Sensoren, für meine Waage
und für das Thermostat im Bad.
Nicht für das Thermostat, für das Thermometer im Bad.
Ging alles über
Low Energy Bluetooth.
Der Wattchamp, genau.
Kannst du mir mal erklären, warum das gefühlt nicht...
Tja, das frage ich mich auch.
Wahrscheinlich, weil wir es mit
Internetausbau und generell Infrastruktur
hier halt nicht haben.
Und ich habe so meine Zweifel, wenn im Oktober
gewählt wird
und da wirklich
irgendwie
mit den Grünen was rauskommt,
ob das besser wird.
Dass die anderen das besser hinkriegen.
Hat man jetzt die letzten Jahre gesehen.
Aber da habe ich noch
größere Zweifel dran, ob das dann was wird.
Tja, frage ich mich auch.
Wie findest du OpenSense
oder PFSense oder OpenSense?
PFSense
muss ich dir ehrlich sagen, habe ich nie
großartig lange benutzt.
PFSense hatte ich eine ganze Weile, bestimmt
zwei Jahre hier im Einsatz.
Echt nice.
Auch relativ gut bedienbar
für jemand, der nicht so genau durchblickt bei der
ganzen Geschichte.
Gerade auch das Portal für WLAN, richtig, richtig gut.
Finde ich nice.
Kann man empfehlen.
Hast du irgendwelche Ziele dieses Jahr?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich will endlich 300.000
Abos auf YouTube haben.
Jetzt ernsthaft.
Guck mal, wie lange ich jetzt schon wieder
konstant dabei bin Videos zu machen.
Das habe ich das letzte Mal vor 7 Jahren gemacht.
Und ich glaube morgen
habe ich 285.000
Abos.
Es geht echt aufwärts.
Ich habe so viele Abos wie noch nie
auf YouTube.
Ich habe in den letzten 6 Jahren über ein bisschen was verloren.
Weil ich halt nichts gemacht habe.
Aber es geht aufwärts.
So zwischen 1000
und 3000
im Monat.
Es ist natürlich bei weitem nicht mehr das, was ich gemacht habe
früher. Ist ja logisch.
Wo ich irgendwelche Hype Call of Duty Sachen gemacht habe.
Aber du kannst dich echt nicht beschweren
hier im Endeffekt.
Ich habe 600.000 Aufrufe.
Ähm.
Subscribers.
Wunderbar, ja.
Ich streame schon seit 4 Jahren.
Das kommt mir echt nicht so lange vor.
Ich komme immer noch wie der größte
Kack-Stream-Loop vor.
Ich habe kein Overlay.
Ich habe kein Intro.
Ich habe keine gescheiten Wots ohne Musik.
Ich habe keine Overlays.
Keine Anzeigen. Nichts.
Ich habe einfach gar nichts bei meinem Stream.
Da könnte man sicherlich
auch noch richtig viele geile Sachen machen.
Aber mache ich halt nicht.
Weil ich total faul bin, was sowas angeht.
Aber mein...
Wie gesagt, demnächst gibt es den 3D-Keks.
Hier noch ein Motivationsvideo.
Wetten?
Das ist ein Rig-Roll-Video, Leute.
Ich antizipiere schon
ein Rig-Roll-Video.
Oder ein Monka-Toss-Video.
Hahaha.
War mir klar.
Voll komplett klar.
Das war kein Cheatbaited,
weil ich habe es schon erraten, erahnt.
Ja, also wie gesagt, 300k
will ich haben dieses Jahr.
Oder zumindest
nahe hinkommen, dass ich es am Anfang nächsten Jahres schaffe.
Aber 300k bis Ende des Jahres
wäre schon cool.
Ich mache noch ein paar Co-Operations.
Das bringt immer was. Und das bringt
beiden Seiten was. Deswegen ist das ganz cool.
Ich plane gerade ein Video.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr ihn kennt.
Ich plane gerade ein Video mit...
Wobei ich das nicht...
Ich kann das doch nicht mal schreiben, Alter.
Nicht für
Big-Abo-Stells machen in dem Fall.
Sondern macht echt gute Videos.
Wir wollen ein Video machen zum Thema
Was ist die beste
Programmiersprache für Einsteiger?
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Ihr müsst jetzt
sehr stark sein.
Also wir haben uns darauf geeinigt.
Wir werden wohl
C Sharp nehmen.
Python nehmen. Go nehmen.
Und er will allen Ernstes C++ nehmen.
Aber hey.
Er kann in seiner Part machen,
was er will.
Ich werde nichts sagen zu.
Ihr wisst,
dass ich kein C++ Fan bin.
Wobei ich glaube, er will gar nicht C++ nehmen.
Ich glaube, er will eigentlich sagen
C
und zwar für Sachen,
wo es halt sinnvoll ist.
Falls man mit
Arduinos und sowas anfängt,
dann ist halt eben C++ ein super Einstieg.
Weil es das einzige ist, was du machen kannst.
So.
Also da werden wir demnächst was zusammen machen.
Ist auf jeden Fall auch ein super Channel.
Wenn man sich für diese Thematik hier interessiert.
Also kann man sich
durchaus geben.
Und ich habe letztens was unter seinem Video kommentiert.
Und dann hat YouTube das erstmal gesperrt.
Weil YouTube gedacht hat, es wäre Spam.
Ich habe unter seinem Video geschrieben,
dass wir nächstes mal was zusammen aufnehmen
oder sowas.
Und es hat YouTube erstmal gesperrt.
Weil es gesagt hat, es wäre Spam.
Bitcoin? Nein, ich habe keine Bitcoin.
Ich hätte gerne Bitcoin.
Aber nicht jetzt, sondern
ich hätte jetzt gerne welche gehabt.
Hä, was?
Der Amt-Champ.
Was, Latenz, wenn man die Strecke mit dem...
Was?
Kann man machen.
Musst du dir halt überlegen, was du eigentlich vorhast.
Was willst du damit bezwecken?
Also was hast du vor?
Was kannst du jetzt mit deiner aktuellen Hardware nicht machen?
Wozu brauchst du das?
Weil ich bin mittlerweile komplett davon abgekommen,
Sachen zu installieren oder Sachen im Einsatz zu haben,
einfach nur weil es geht.
Wobei, ihr wisst, dass ich mich eigentlich selbst
gebatet mit dieser Aussage.
Das stimmt nämlich überhaupt nicht.
Ich rede mir das immer ein.
Dass ich nur Sachen im Einsatz habe, die sinnvoll sind
und nicht weil es geht.
Aber ich habe sicherlich genug Zeugs im Einsatz,
weil es geht und nicht unbedingt, weil es sinnvoll ist.
Kannst du Stonks-Tipps geben?
Ich kann Stonks-Memes einblenden.
Das war's.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Sorry, muss wohl mit Adwoblors.
Ja, muss. Ansonsten sehe ich es manchmal nicht.
Max, ich schaue seit langem deine Videos.
Wollte erst mal Danke sagen.
Exzellent, dass du deinen W-Share gefunden hast.
Boah, Corona-Attacke gerade gehabt.
Muss ich mich muten?
Also.
Schau seit langem deine Videos.
Wie ich hergefunden hast, wollte erst mal Danke sagen.
Zu dem Internet-Ausbau durfte
bis vor kurzem noch mit DSL.
Ja, das ist halt richtig massiver Pains-Champ.
Äh, äh.
Und bis jetzt Glasfaser und...
Ja, nice, nice. Hast du Glück gehabt.
Ja.
Von der Steinzeit in die Zukunft.
Was mich stört ist, dass Frauen auf gewissen Seiten so hochauflösend sind,
dass ich den...
Jeder hat so seinen Geschmack, ja.
Nee, das ist kein Toss.
Das ist kein Toss.
Toss wäre das nur mit Bild.
Das stimmt.
Dafür habe ich das Meme-Board, was eigentlich das
allerbeste ist, was ich hier je programmiert habe.
Ich meine,
wenigstens mal was, was ich sinnvoll verwenden kann.
Ich meine, der Code ist natürlich unter aller Sau,
aber es funktioniert.
Ich meine, wer hat so was cooles, hä?
Keiner.
Beste, beste
Meme-Stream-Twitch.
So, also. Zack.
Zack.
Ja, ist das ja auch im Endeffekt.
Ist das ja auch, oder?
Aber ganz ehrlich,
das ist
für mich auch der Gedanke
hinter Twitch.
Diese ganzen Sachen, die aktuell da gerade
angesagt sind,
ist für mich nicht
so
der alte Twitch-Ger.
Ist ein bisschen wie bei YouTube früher.
Früher hatte YouTube Broadcast Yourself als Motto.
Da sind wir ja auf YouTube mittlerweile komplett
weg. Für mich ist...
Ist so...
Ist so der alte Twitch-Geist.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man sich...
Weiß nicht, ob ihr Dance-Gaming guckt.
Dance-Gaming ist der einzige Let's Player, den ich mir angucken kann.
Und...
Ich fande
so die Oldschool-Twitch-Zeit irgendwie cooler.
Man muss halt mal sagen,
in professionelle Richtungen hat sich das mit Amazon schon...
Also, nee, umgedreht.
Es hat sich seit der Amazon-Übernahme
schon in deutlich professionellere Richtungen
entwickelt.
Ja, auch mit den Möglichkeiten.
Ist schon gut. Es wird ja aktuell total
schlecht geredet. Insgesamt ist die Plattform
wahrscheinlich attraktiver als jemals
zuvor.
Aber trotzdem, so die
Oldschool-Vibes sind schon... Ja, oder
der Forsen-Chat oder sowas. Ich habe am Anfang auch gerne
XQC geguckt, aber mittlerweile
kann ich mir das nicht mehr geben,
weil es ist...
Also erstens macht der Content nämlich nicht mehr interessiert
und der Chat ist mittlerweile so krass
voll gespammt und sinnlos, dass da gar nichts mehr
geht.
Ja.
Das sehe ich auch so.
Abap. Wir haben hier wirklich
Leute mit komischen Vorlieben.
Sucked.
Kann das PPGaBoard Dark Mode
sein?
Nur mit Addon.
Ich habe, glaube, kein Dark Reader Addon.
PPGaBoard
kann nur mit Addon Dark Reader sein.
Was hältst du von
Bitcoin? Oh, da muss ich jetzt zu weit
ausholen.
Da muss ich jetzt zu weit ausholen und ihr wisst,
Boomer schlafen gleich.
Kann ich jetzt...
Können wir uns im nächsten Stream...
Kann ich was zu sagen?
Was? Sag mal, hast du bestimmt Ahnung
von Hardware es geht? Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich habe immer nur Ahnung von Hardware,
wenn ich mir was kaufen will.
Ist meine Frage, dass ich
bei meinem PC upgrade...
Es ist gerade eine schlechte Zeit, Hardware zu kaufen.
Ach, Moment.
Geht um einen Lautsprecher. Ich will mir eine neue
5.1 Box für den PC kaufen und da brauche ich
doch bestimmt auch eine gute Soundkarte
oder... Ne, kann ich dir nichts empfehlen.
Wobei,
willst du das zum Videos gucken oder
zum Spielen? Also 5.1
Boxen
zum Spielen
kann man sicherlich machen,
wenn der Raum groß genug ist.
Aber ich persönlich
bevorzuge ja ganz normale
Stereo Kopfhörer
und virtuelles Surround.
Aber ne, ich kann dir keine Soundkarte empfehlen.
Kenn ich mich nicht
mit aus.
Gerade bei solchen advanced Sachen.
Ich hab mein Audio Interface hier.
Kopfhörer dran, fertig.
Das Memeboard...
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Kann ich nicht.
Und das Memeboard ist Open Source, aber
nur eine uralte Version.
Den Rest habe ich noch nicht hochgeladen und werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Weil da muss ich mich ja schämen für.
Aber die Memes gibt es
alle irgendwie über Google oder sonst wie.
Oder, na manche
zum Beispiel der, den hat
irgendein Mod, ich glaube der Serious Max war das damals
sogar, hat den erstellt für den Stream.
Nein.
Ich finds lustig, wie das
die Leute immer probieren, aber es funktioniert nicht.
Nice.
Ich bin dumm gewesen, ich hab mein
N64 und meine Wii weggeschmissen
beim umziehen.
Aber die Spiele habe ich behalten, lustigerweise
vom N64.
Die Standard Firmware ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Was kostet denn eigentlich ein
N64 gerade, wenn ich mir einen kaufen will?
In schwarz.
Ja, ich glaube die gab es nur in schwarz, oder?
Ne, die gab es glaube ich auch in anderen Farben.
50 Euro.
Vielleicht sollte ich mir nochmal
den N64 kaufen.
Wann gibt es dann wieder 10++-Stellen?
Solange ich es vermeiden kann, gibt es das nie.
Na gucke mal, hier für 65 Euro
ein N64 mit 4 Controller
vom Spielepapa.
200 Euro.
Warum ist das so ultra teuer?
Achso, weil es gebraucht ist, aber die anderen sind auch
bestimmt gebraucht.
Ja, das mit den Sachen zu emulieren
ist kein Ding, ja. Aber so eine
echte Konsole hätte ich... Ich habe ja die Spiele hier noch.
Also, wäre eigentlich schon cool,
wenn ich mir wieder einen holen würde.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob die nicht auf Github
ihren Kram haben.
Anscheinend nicht.
Ja, dann kannst du es mit das Motor flashen, das geht auch.
Das Motor läuft da 1 zu 1
out of the box drauf.
Ganz ehrlich, die Sachen spielt man am Ende doch
eh nicht.
Kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen.
Ich könnte
mich da schon sehen, bis ich den N64 spiele.
Japp hab nur ich.
Ich bin der einzige, der
Japp hat, als Emote.
Der Chat kriegt kein Japp.
Warnix, dankeschön für die 4 Monate
Subscription.
Ich glaube, ich habe eben noch jemanden übersehen.
Wartet mal, ich guck mal kurz.
RealMarx, dankeschön, vor 3 Minuten
ein Prime-Sub. Poggers.
Max Headroom, Prime-Subscription vor 13 Minuten.
Dankeschön.
Und da Sebix und Leko auch noch hier.
Huge Stubs.
Wieder die Hälfte übersehen hier.
Ebay Kleinanzeigen, was?
Letzter Preis.
Habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich sind es irgendwelche
Microcontroller mit
irgendwelche Sachen, die mit C programmiert werden.
Gehe ich mal von aus.
Oder Windows 95.
Ohne Mist, kann tatsächlich sein.
Kennst du Leute,
die nur Open Source Software benutzen und vorher
den Code lesen? Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich kenne ein paar so richtig krasse Open Source
Hardware Fanatiker.
Nicht Hardware, Hardcore Fanatiker.
Aber selbst die lesen nicht jeden Code,
für den sie...
Also, ich kenne beispielsweise auch niemanden mehr,
der Gentoo benutzt.
Ich hatte mal einen Kollegen, der hat Gentoo benutzt.
Der hat 2 Tage gebraucht, bis er sein Notebook in Betrieb
nehmen konnte, weil er
den Netzwerktreiber
irgendwie 20 mal kompilieren musste,
bis die Netzwerkkarte funktioniert.
Aber ich kenne keinen mehr, der Gentoo benutzt.
Ich benutze übrigens Arch,
falls euch das interessiert.
By the way,
guckst du Semper Videos?
Die Streams gucke ich nicht.
Ich habe ihn ein paar mal gehostet.
Aber die Videos gucke ich öfters mal.
Moin.
Wie geht es dem Friseur? Dem Friseur geht es gut.
Was ist denn der DC?
Dem Friseur geht es gut.
Wenn du dich fragst, was der Friseur macht,
der Friseur kreiselgrindet
in MMOs
8,5 Stunden am Tag.
Im Kreis.
Mit Webcam im Vergleich.
Aber bald gibt es die Keks-Cam.
Ach, auf dem Discord,
der Gentoo benutzen will.
Ja, es gibt Leute,
die können es nicht sein lassen.
Okay, Leute, ich muss jetzt pennen.
22 Uhr, morgen wieder arbeiten.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Ach, wir brauchen Outromusik, oder?
Vielleicht haben wir irgendjemand kleineres,
dem ich follow,
der den Host gebrauchen kann.
Ach, guck mal, Semper Video ist am Start.
Komm, raiden wir Semper Video.
Ups, falsches Chatfenster.
Raiden wir Semper Video
und spammen
eine Runde, keine Ahnung,
Wubgesm.
Hehehe.
Also,
bis dann, macht es gut.
Wir sehen uns.
Spammen mag er nicht.
Da muss er jetzt durch.
Bis dann, macht es gut.